assembly language is a low-level
programming language for a computer or
other programmable device that is
closest to the machine language it is
often specific to a particular computer
architecture so there are multiple types
of assembly languages arm is an
increasingly popular assembly language
scott cosentino teaches this course
about assembly programming with arm
scott is a popular technical instructor
and author
it is estimated that over 200 billion
devices contain an arm chip making the
arm language valuable to understand
by understanding the arm assembly
language
programmers can work at a lower level
allowing them to write code that
interacts with hardware in an efficient
manner
by the end of this course you will have
a fundamental understanding of the arm
processor as well as assembly
programming in general you will be able
to write basic arm assembly programs
using various instructions available in
the processor i encourage you to share
the most interesting thing you learn in
the comments for the benefit of other
campers who are watching this course
hello and welcome i'm excited today to
be presenting to you an introduction to
the arm assembly language
the main goal of this course is really
to give you an introduction to the ideas
of low-level programming through
assembly languages as well as working
with the arm programming language in
general
arm is a programming language that's
used in a variety of different
applications you see it in a lot of
different embedded devices and really
popular devices such as different phones
a lot of android devices and some iphone
devices are running arm-based chips and
we're also starting to see them become a
lot more
used in a lot of laptops like the new
macbooks are actually using arm-based
processors because of this it's become a
really important skill to actually
understand how arm processors work
and how you're actually able to program
directly with them this is because
working at a lower level lets you be
closer to the hardware so let's see
write better interactions between the
hardware and the software now to more
efficiently interact between hardware in
any situations where you might need to
do something like this
generally this course is going to give
you a good familiarity with the ideas of
arm including some of the basic
instructions that arm has the different
ways that arithmetic works and different
operations such as logical operators and
shift operators that are commonly used
in the level assembly languages we'll
take a look at different ways that we
can branch as well as loop inside of
assembly languages and then finally
we'll finish off by taking a look at
some hardware interactions as well as
the different ways that we can use and
troubleshoot arm assembly in a linux
based system
now i'm going to primarily be using an
emulator known as cpu later as it's very
easy for you to follow along with this
on the actual web browser that you have
so for the most part you want to install
any sort of
special equipment in order to make this
work the main approach here is to make
sure that you can be able to interact
with this course and follow along easily
without any sort of special
prerequisites now the last few videos
here are going to be linux based so you
will need some linux based machine or
virtual device to be able to follow
along with those but overall even if you
just follow along with the emulator ones
you'll come away from this course with a
very strong understanding of arm as well
as assembly languages
so i hope that this course is valuable
for you and i hope that you enjoy it
if you enjoy it please feel free to
leave a comment and let me know and if
you have any sort of questions also let
me know and i'm happy to answer anything
that may come up
so in this video i'm going to spend some
time just discussing the general idea of
our architecture of our arm processor as
well as getting familiarized a little
bit with the development environment
that i'm going to be using in this set
of videos which is actually the cpu
later emulator this emulator is
available online for free so you can
access it
from pretty much any computer
and inside of this emulator we have a
lot of different
different architectures that exist for
us the one that we're mainly interested
in is arm v7
if you're familiar with mips or any
other assembly language like that you'll
see that those emulators are also
available for you
but generally we're going to be working
in an arm v7 architecture and
specifically in this set of videos i'm
going to demonstrate the arm v7 de1 soc
um so this will be the one that we'll
utilize throughout this series of videos
so i'll press go and we'll head into the
emulator
just to note if you're following along
you can follow along through the
emulator here or you can follow along on
your own computer if you have an arm
processor of some sort any v7 processor
you'll be able to follow along fine with
even earlier ones you'll probably be
able to follow along relatively well
the main goal of this video is not just
to teach you arm based assembly but also
to teach you the general principles of
assembly so that you can easily
adapt to any other assembly language
things like x86
other versions of arm and so on like
that
so in general the principles that you
learn throughout this series of videos
are going to apply to really any
assembly language with the syntax
specifically being targeted towards arm
processors
so when we get into our emulator there
are a few things that we have available
to us well there's actually like a lot
of things on the screen that we have
available to us and i'm going to walk
you through some of the essential pieces
that we need just to get started
so the first idea that i'm going to
introduce to you is the idea of
registers which we see over here on the
left hand side
registers are areas in memory that are
very close to the cpu so they can be
accessed quickly and they could be
written too quickly
so the general storage is going to be
relatively fast however we have a
limited amount of things that we can
store inside of these registers
you'll notice that there's eight zeros
inside of this register
each zero represents a single
hexadecimal value now if you know about
hexadecimal you'll know that hexadecimal
is going to represent four bits so each
hex value represents four bits of data
since there's eight hex values each one
represents four bits we have a total of
32 bits that we can work with
this is because this general processor
is a 32-bit processor so we're going to
be working in 32 bits and that's the
constraint of how much we can store in a
single register is 32 bits worth of data
we'll often refer to 32 bits as a word
in terms of the size so if you ever hear
me refer to as you know changing a
word's worth of data i'm referring to 32
bits of data
the idea of a word transitions to other
assembly languages as well and it
generally represents the total like max
size of data that could be stored in a
register so for instance if you're in a
64-bit processor a word would be 64 bits
in size and then we have the concept of
a half word which is half the size of a
word so in 32 bits a half word is 16
bits because it's half of 32. in 64 bits
a half word is 32 bits because it's half
of 64.
and then of course we have a byte which
is always eight bits and then we have a
single bit of data so those are sort of
the different sizes that we have
available to us
so in general when we're working an
assembly we want to try to use these
registers as much as possible so all of
these registers are going to be
available to us
with the exception that some of them are
going to have special purposes
associated with them that we'll discuss
some as we start to see those special
purposes later on
in general i can say that
registers r0 to r6 our general purpose
we can use them for whatever storage
we'd like to use them for r7 is going to
have a special functionality to us
related to system calls essentially when
we when we are working with assembly
sometimes we need to talk to the
operating system and we need to ask it
for maybe a resource or we need to ask
it to terminate or program when we
you know call to the operating system to
ask it to do something for us it needs
to know what we're asking it to do
and the way that we communicate that is
by storing a value in r7 and that value
will be some numeric value that it will
map in a table to
some some specific like action so for
instance if i store the value 1 in r7
and then i interrupt the program the
operating system will read that and
interpret it as end the program so
that's an example of how we might use
that
so that's one example of a special
purpose register that we have
now there are other special purpose
registers that are actually labeled in
this emulator
splr and pc
sp is a really interesting one which is
related to the stack pointer and that
actually introduces us to our next
important concept which is the concept
of stack memory
if you head over to the memory section
here you'll see that you have a whole
bunch of memory available to us and this
is referred to as stack memory
stack memory is typically stored in the
ram of the computer
and essentially it's slower to access
and slower to write to however we can
store a lot more data in ram comparative
to data in registers
you'll typically see stack memory used
when we want to represent more complex
sets of data think of something like a
list of numbers for instance if i were
representing a list of numbers i could
give each
location in memory a specific number and
then i can iterate through those memory
locations to get those numbers that
would be an example of when we might use
stack memory
so the sp register is always going to be
telling us the address of the next
available piece of memory on the stack
so in this case you see it's pointing to
all zeros which means that we are
sitting at this location here
now
in order to determine like the actual
locations um we can think a little bit
about like where each address is so this
one is zero we can ask what is the
address next to this
it's always going to be four
larger than the previous so this is that
address zero this would be at address
four this would be at address eight this
would be at address twelve and then we
land here at address 16. now you might
look at this and say well it says 1 0
isn't that 10.
remember that we're working in hex 1 0
in hex is 16 in decimal so just keep
that in mind that you're always working
in hexadecimal so that's just something
to keep in mind there and that's the way
that our stack memory grows and you'll
get really familiar with stack memory
we're going to work with it a lot
throughout this series of videos so
you'll get a really good understanding
of this as you continue to work with it
the lr register is another interesting
one it's known as our link register and
the best way to describe this is if
you've ever worked in a higher level
language before you'll know that when
you have a function a function has a
return and that return allows us to move
back to the location of what called the
function that's what the link register
stores it stores the location that a
function should return back to so we'll
see that when we talk about functions in
future videos
and then finally the pc is our program
counter what this does is it keeps track
of the location of the next instruction
to execute so
all of our instructions are stored in
memory like all the different uh things
that we're asking the program to do and
the program counter allows us to move
through piece by piece and determine
where the next instruction is going to
be located
so those are three really important
registers to keep in mind and like i
said some of these other registers have
special purposes as well and we'll
discuss those as they become relevant to
us as we continue on through this
the one final thing that i'll discuss
here is our cpsr register and our spsr
register
our cpsr register is a special type of
register that is used to store
information about our program
so an example of some of the information
that it might store if you subtract two
numbers from each other you might end up
with a negative number
now if you remember in binary when we
want to represent negative numbers we
need to use what's known as two's
complement
two's complement essentially um you know
it goes through some conversion
mechanism in order to convert us into
that format we have to do the ones
complement and then we do the two's
complement and we end up with some
number that represents a negative number
the issue is that that number could also
be a positive number so it's both
positive and negative but we need to
know whether or not it's representing
like a negative number or just a really
large positive number
that's where our cpsr register comes in
what it will do is it will set a flag in
memory to say
the result of the previous operation was
negative
we can then take a look at that register
and say if the result was negative
interpret this as a negative number
otherwise interpret it as a positive
number
that's sort of the purpose of the cpsr
register it has a whole bunch of flags
sort of similar to that that tell us
special information about the operations
you know if a result was negative if a
result was zero if a result had a carry
or an overflow those are the sorts of
ideas that we would typically see so
we'll see those again as we continue on
um learning about the different
operations
so this gives you a general overview of
some of the important components that we
need to start programming in arm
assembly and in the next video we'll
take a look at how to create a really
basic assembly program so that's what
we'll take a look at next
so in this video we're just going to
take a look at a really basic arm
application just to get a really good
fundamental feel of the structure of our
programs as well as the way that they
actually run so we're going to go over a
lot of the important concepts of you
know where the starting point of our
application is where the ending point of
our application is and
how can we do all the things in between
so starting off with this idea let's
discuss the starting point of our
program
you'll see that our emulator
automatically puts in two lines for us
now if you're programming outside of the
emulator you won't have these two lines
added by default you have to add them
yourself but they are essential because
they tell us the starting point of our
application so let me break down the
lines one by one here
i'm going to start backwards with this
underscore start portion here
this is known as a label
a label is sort of synonymous with a
function in higher level languages it's
a way of being able to divide out
segments of code such that if you go to
the label you start to execute the code
that is underneath that label
the idea of this is that we set up a
start label
which then we are able to say okay go to
the start and start running the stuff
that's there
that's the idea of what we're looking to
do so that's why we define our start
label
and then our global underscore start
here as a way of being able to tell
people about the start label
so someone is going to be running our
program so at some point something is
going to be running our program it needs
to know where the starting point is as
well
when we define labels by default they
aren't available to anything external to
our program the dot global is telling
everyone else about our start label so
if anyone ever approaches their program
and says i want to run you where is the
start the start is exported via this
global which means that everything is
able to see where the starting point is
therefore things are able to go to the
starting point to start executing our
program
so this is the general idea of sort of
like our main starting point of our
application
so everything that we write is going to
be underneath this start label
so that's where we're going to start
writing our code
and the code that i'm going to write is
going to be very very simple all it's
going to do is it's going to move some
data into register zero that way you can
see how we move data into registers
and then i'm going to move some data
into register seven it might seem a
little bit weird that i'm jumping
straight to register seven
the reason being is because register 7
is a special purpose register
what it does is it stores information
about system calls
when we go to the operating system we
often want to ask it to do specific
things for us right the operating system
manages input it manages output it
manages
the execution of programs so if we need
the operating system to do something for
us we need some method of communicating
with it
this method of communication comes in
two pieces the first is in system
interrupts and the second is in
system call numbers
so we place a special number into
register seven and that tells the
operating system what we would like it
to do so basically we place the number
into r7 and then we call an interrupt
the interrupt goes to the operating
system and it says hey we need something
done the operating system comes in and
it reads register 7 which has some
number inside of it it takes that number
and it compares it to like a lookup
table and it says okay well that number
corresponds with this task and then it
completes that task for us
in our case our task is very simple we
want our program to end
so if i want to terminate the execution
of my program what i do is i move the
number one into r7
and then i call an interrupt the
operating system then goes to register
seven it says oh i see the number one
here it goes to its little table and its
table says one corresponds to exit the
program and then it terminates the
program for us
so that shows us how we end our program
so let's take a look at how that's
actually written so the first thing i
want to do is move some data into r0
that way we can see
just generally how we can move data into
registers and what that looks like
during execution
so the way that we do this is as follows
we're going to start by writing in
what's called an opcode well you'll see
it set in a number of different ways
either up code operation
mnemonic is also used i'm going to refer
to them as operations or opcodes
so we're going to start by writing in
the operation that corresponds to moving
data and that is mov
now i use capital letters for mine you
don't have to do that you can write it
in lowercase as well
i just prefer this convention and this
is the one that i'm most um most
comfortable with so this is the way that
i usually end up writing it
so the way that our move operation
actually works is it moves data into
locations right
specifically we're going to move data
into registers
so what we need to do is we need to
provide it with two things we need to
give it a destination for our data as
well as a source for our data so the
source is where we're getting the data
from the destination is where the data
is ending up the destination is the
first argument given to this operation
and then the source is the second
argument so my destination in this case
where i want to store the data is r0
again i put a capital r you don't have
to you can use a lowercase r um it's not
actually case sensitive i just prefer
the convention for capital letters so
that's what you'll see me use
so i'm going to move into r0
the value so i put a comma and now i'm
going to specify the source so my source
could be a number of different things
and we're going to go through these
different things as we continue learning
about assembly because we can we can
move data from registers we can move
data from memory so we can do all sorts
of things like that in this case i'm
going to be moving a constant value into
this register
so the way that we do this is we put in
a hashtag and then we put in the value
that we want to move in i want to move
in the number 30 in decimal so i just
put hashtag 30.
all this does is it takes the number 30
it places it into register zero
and that's it that's how we move the
data into the register now one thing i
want to point out to you is that you can
put hex into these registers as well the
way that you do that is you put zero x
and then the hex value that you want to
put in so for instance 0x
0a we write the value 0a into register
0.
so i just want to point out that that's
the way that you do hex in this case i'm
working in decimal and i'm pretty much
always going to be working in decimal
unless i have a very specific reason to
be using hex um just because i'm most
comfortable with decimals so that's what
you'll see me using throughout this
so i move 30 into register zero and now
we're going to do our portion that ends
the program so remember i said that i
wanted to move into registers 7 the
value 1 because one indicates that we're
going to exit our program
and then i want to do a an interrupt the
way i do this is as follows i say swi
0.
swi is a software interrupt what it does
is it interrupts the program and it lets
the operating system take over
like i said before the operating system
then reads the value in r7 that value is
1. it takes the one it checks the lookup
table it says okay well one says that we
should terminate the program and so
we're done
so that's really all there is to that so
nice straightforward simple let's go
ahead and compile and run this
so i'm going to click on compile and
load
and as you can see it compiles our
program together and we are now in our
disassembly tab and we can see each of
the instructions as it interprets them
now i will note to you that this
emulator doesn't really do well with swi
it doesn't really understand software
interrupts all too well i'm writing this
as if you were writing it for an actual
arm processor if you're writing this on
say like a raspberry pi that runs on arm
swi is going to be what you're going to
use um but our emulator won't end up
like executing it properly so it's just
a note just a little quirk of the
emulator unfortunately but um if you're
running on an actual arm processor this
is what you would end up using so that's
why i'm teaching that instead of
something more specific to this emulator
so
let's walk through these operations so
remember the first thing is moving 30
into r0
if i press step into it will execute
that instruction
now i want to point out a few important
things
the first important thing is you can see
that r0 now has the value 1e inside of
it which i will tell you is the same as
30 in decimal
if you wanted to verify that you can
actually come down to the settings here
under format you can go to decimal
unsigned or decimal signed decimal sign
assumes that there's negative numbers
decimal unsigned assumes that everything
is positive
so we can go decimal unsigned since
everything is positive you can see that
that gives us a value of 30.
so you can see that's how we convert
between like the hex and the um and the
actual decimal value so that's that's
something uh that we're able to do
now one additional thing that i want to
mention is you can see that we stored
one e inside of here if you're familiar
with converting hex to binary you'll
know how to read the binary for this and
you can see that in general the most
significant bit is on the left most side
we actually refer to this as a specific
type of storage known as little indian
so little indian refers to the most
significant bit being on the left hand
side that's the way that arm functions
as well as many other processors but an
interesting thing about arm is that
actually can be used
the opposite way as well so the most
significant bit on the right hand side
which is known as big indian
we would say that arm is actually a
bi-indian processor because we can
change where the most significant bit is
depending on what we're doing
so that's just something that i wanted
to note about like how things are
actually being stored in those registers
then the last thing that i want to point
out here is the idea of the program
counter
so the program counter is telling us
where we're currently located in terms
of instructions you can see right now
it's equal to four and at address four
we have our move for one into r7
so i just wanted to
you know pull some attention towards how
the program counter was using that way
you can get a bit more context compared
to the last video where i just told you
what it was doing now you can actually
see it in action
so you can see in our next instruction
we step into r7 gets a value of one and
then we would end up doing a system
interrupt and that would end our program
and that's really all there is to it
this is a really basic assembly program
that we've now written so you've now
gotten the basic fundamentals of writing
a program and what the actual
architecture is generally looking like
in the next few videos that i that i put
up i'm going to discuss a little bit
about um the different uh addressing
modes that we have available to us the
different ways that we can move data to
and from registers as well as storing in
the stack memory so we'll discuss a lot
more about memory storage and then from
there we can start to take a look at
some some more advanced operations and
then some actual like algorithms and
building some interesting stuff with our
processor
so in this video we're going to take a
look at the different addressing types
that exist inside of arm as well as
other assembly languages and the general
idea of addressing types is that they're
ways that we're able to store and
retrieve data from the various memory
locations that we have
so for example in the previous video we
used a type of addressing that is known
as
immediate addressing and that's when we
want to move into a register a specific
value that is constant so whenever we
have like a constant value like this 5
on this side being moved into a register
r0 we call this immediate addressing
because we're taking an immediate value
and we're placing it into a register
a similar type of register type movement
that we have is moving between two
different registers so if i want to move
now what's in r0 into r1 this would be
called register direct addressing so
we're directly moving a value from run
register into another so those are two
types of addressing that we have that
work with the register memory and
they're the most common ones that we'll
typically see when we're working with
registers
now the more interesting type of
addressing that we have has to deal with
data that's stored in the stack so to
demonstrate this i'm going to go ahead
and show you how to get data onto the
stack first and then we'll take a look
at how we can work with the data that's
on the stack
so first off how do we get data onto the
stack
to do this we have to use a data section
in our application and the way that we
do that is we just type in data this is
going to come below all of our like
global start portion here so you say i
put it just right down here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to declare any data that we want
to put in our stack memory and we do
this in the way of giving it a label
which basically functions like a
variable name
we then declare the type of the variable
and then the data that's actually stored
inside of it
so for example i'm going to declare some
data i'm going to name the data list i'm
going to put list colon
and then i'm going to go to the next
line and i usually like to indent to put
the next portion here just to organize
it nicely
and in this case i want to store a list
of numbers
so in this case when we're dealing with
numbers numbers are going to be a
specific size in this case i want to
work with 32-bit numbers and as we've
discussed 32 bits is considered to be a
word so i'm going to type in dot word
this tells it that every single one of
the values that follows should be
treated as a word type which means that
they have 32 bits in size notice that we
don't say like it's an integer or it's a
float or anything like that assembly
it's very basic it's basically just got
those those basic sorts of data types
usually you're going to see things like
ascii or you're going to see things like
the actual size like word or half word
or byte or something like that
so in this case now we can just start
listing off the numbers we want to put
inside of our list so i'll just put some
some random numbers in it doesn't really
matter what numbers you use i'm putting
in some some positives and some
negatives so you can see the different
types that exist
now the very first thing that i need to
do is i need to be able to retrieve
where this list is located in memory
and what we do is we typically look for
the first entry in the list
and then everything is going to follow
sequentially from there and basically
what's going to happen is that they're
going to appear in every single like
slot in memory sequential from the first
one so you'll see that when we actually
load up this program
so in order to get the first memory
location into a register we want it in a
register so that we can actually work
with it and manipulate it it's easier to
work in the registers than it is to work
in the stack so we want to get it into
the register first and to do this we're
going to use an instruction known as ldr
and what ldr lets us do is it lets us
load data from stack into registers
that's the main purpose of it
so i'm going to load into register r0
the location of the first value in our
list variable
so this equals list indicates that i'm
dealing with this list in my data
section and what it's going to do is
it's going to find out where this first
value is located
and it's going to place it into register
0.
this is known as direct addressing
and this is how we essentially
initialize the location of our list
so let's compile and load and see what
happens
i'm going to go ahead and step into this
ldr instruction and we're going to see
that it's going to store the value 8
into the register r0 so what does that
mean
it means that if i come into memory
and i go over to memory location 8 so
this is 0 this is 4 this is 8 right here
you can see that this looks like the
start of my list so if we look we have
four five negative nine one zero two
negative three so i've got four five
this might look a little bit weird it
helps to switch over our view here in
our settings to decimal signed to see it
a bit more clear you can see that that's
negative 9.
just as a little reminder the reason why
we see it like this is because it's
stored in two's complement right so we
have all the f's which is all the ones
and then the actual number there right
so you can see that that's generally how
that's stored but this helps us see it a
little bit more clear so you can see
that these are all the entries inside of
our list
so that's that's nice and easy to look
at
and now we actually have the location of
the first value in our list
so that's nice that we have that
location the next question is well how
do we actually retrieve the value from
that location
and the answer is that we have to use
another type of addressing mode and this
one is known as register indirect
addressing
and the way that that works is that we
still use ldr because we're moving from
the stack into the register
and what i'm going to do in this case is
i'm going to load into register r1
the value that exists at the address
of r0
so these square brackets tell our
assembler that we're really looking to
find the value associated with the
address in r0 so when we compile and
load this what's going to happen is in
this case we get 10 as our value in r0
or 1 0. so
you can see that it changes every time
that i compile and run it that's totally
normal every single time that you run it
the memory structure will be slightly
different which is why we sort of have
to do more dynamic loading like we're
doing rather than hard coding numbers in
such as something to note as well
so you can see that r0 is equal to 10.
we come into memory we can see that
indeed 10 does look to be the location
of the first element
when we do our next instruction this ldr
r1 and then the square brackets are zero
what it does is it takes a look and it
says okay well in r0 we have this value
here and then what it will say is it'll
say okay let's go to that memory address
what's stored in that memory address
okay four is stored in that memory
address so we'll return that back as our
result
and you can see that's exactly what we
get is four
so just to give you a little bit of an
analogy if you're thinking about like
other programming languages it always
helps to think about this sort of like a
high-level world as well um in a lot of
programming languages you might have
like a list um you know i could do like
a python like list for instance and we
can have like our different values
like this
and what we're doing with this um with
this uh register indirect addressing is
we're basically just trying to find the
lists value at i
where i is r0 so it's really like the
list value at r0 that's basically what
we're looking to do with this so that's
just something to note
now there are other ways that we can
access values off of this list
one such way would be to use register
indirect with an offset
what an offset does is it starts with
the value in r0 so for example in this
case it's currently 10 it adds some
offset to it and then retrieves the
value so for instance what i could do is
i could add 4 to it because if i add 4
to it that would take me to the next
location in memory remember this is 10
this is um 14 here
so i can add 4 to it to get to the next
location in memory and retrieve that
value so that would be an example of
something that we could do so let's see
how we actually do that we would do ldr
in this case i'll put it into r2 in this
case
and we're going to do r0
hashtag 4.
so what this does is it takes the value
in r0
it adds the the form to it and then it
retrieves that value it'd be sort of
like doing r0 plus one
in the high level context i do plus one
here because we're just moving one index
over in the list
remember we're doing four here because
we need to add four
to this address here in order to end up
at this location which is the location
of the next value in memory
so that's just generally how that ends
up working right it's foreign hex for
each stack location
and of course we could do other things
right like we we could add 8 to get to
this we can add 12 to get to this and we
can keep going like that as well um so
that's just something to keep in mind
with this too and just to demonstrate to
you that this really does work let's
compile and load it and let's step into
it we can see we get 10 in this case 4
is the location of the first memory and
then 5 is what's stored at the second
location and we can confirm that that
actually is true we can see five follows
from four so we can see that that does
work the way that i have explained it
which is great
so the last two types of addressing
methods that we'll talk about here are
known as a pre-increment and a
post-increment
so i said previously that the the first
one that we have here is the same as
doing like a list at r0 plus one
with a pre-increment what we would be
doing is we would be incrementing r0
and then we would be accessing the value
at r0 so we essentially increment it and
then we check it
so that's the way that a pre-increment
works so it increments before it
actually gets the value
and the way that this works is we just
put an exclamation mark after this so
it's the same sort of syntax we just put
an exclamation mark that indicates that
this is a pre-increment now
so let's see what ends up happening
when i compile one run this you can see
that i get 10 still 4 is still in this
and you can see what's going to happen
is the result is going to be the same
we're still going to get 5 because it's
going to increment this by 4 which would
take us to location 14. in location 14
we have the value 5 however something
very interesting happens that's
different from the previous example and
that's that r0 changes to 14 afterwards
in the first example where we're doing
just an offset r0 didn't change when we
do a pre-increment which has the
exclamation mark at the end it
increments r0 and axis is at that
specific location
so that's the way this differs from our
offset
and now finally we'll talk about our
post increment our post increment is
very similar to our pre-increment just
difference in when we actually increment
the value right
it'll be the same as doing an access
to our list at r0
and then incrementing our r0 value one
index further
and the way that this is typically
written
is just like this would be r0
and then hashtag 4 like this
so that's generally the way that this
will end up looking
so let's compile and load that and see
what happens
so you can see again we're at 10 as our
starting location 4 ends up being our
value for r1
and then for r2 we end up with the value
4 and then this increments to 14. the
reason why we got the value 4 is because
remember our 0 started at the beginning
which is 10
and then we ended up accessing at that
location giving us 4 and then we
incremented afterwards so remember the
increment comes afterwards rather than
before
so that's the main thing to keep in mind
with that
and that covers all of the different
address loading types that we have
available to us so now you should be
able to comfortably manipulate data and
be able to retrieve from registers and
retrieve from stack memory and we'll use
this throughout various other videos as
we continue on learning arms so you'll
get very familiar with these different
addressing types as we work with them
and you'll see a lot of good
applications of them as well
in this video we're going to discuss
some of the basic arithmetic operations
that exist in arm assembly
in addition to discussing these we're
also going to discuss a few different
modifications to these instructions that
tend to be present in a lot of the
instructions in arm assembly and they
allow us to do very interesting things
like setting the cpsr register after the
instruction is run
and the reason why we're going to
discuss these first with arithmetic
instructions is because arithmetic is
easy everyone sort of knows about adding
and subtracting and multiplying so it's
a very easy sort of place for us to work
with these instructions once we get a
basic understanding of these
instructions we'll take on some of the
more interesting and complex
constructions
allowing us to be able to discuss these
ideas with a solid understanding and
foundation already in place
so to start off with the very basics we
can add subtract and multiply numbers in
arm using a set of instructions the
first is add the second is subtract and
the third is multiply
now you'll notice that division isn't
included in this division turns out to
be a fair bit more complicated than the
other three
instructions so it requires a little bit
more
finesse to get it working so we aren't
going to discuss any division we'll
discuss addition uh subtraction and
multiplication
so when we want to add two numbers
together for instance it's fairly
straightforward to do what i'm going to
do is i'm going to move some data into
some registers so add some we'll put
some numbers into these registers
and then we can use our add operation
our ad operation is going to take in a
destination and two sources so the
destination for this is going to be r2
um and then i'm going to add together
two numbers so i'm going to add together
r0 and r1
and what this is going to do is it's
basically going to do this
it's going to put into r2 the result of
r0 plus r1
so that's all this is really going to do
for us so just going to add the two
numbers together and store the results
in r2 so that's nice and easy let's just
take a look at how this works just to
get comfortable with it so i compile and
load
you see i can load five into register
zero seven into register one i add those
two together and i get c which is equal
to twelve so five plus seven equals
twelve so we could see that the addition
instruction works successfully
so that's the way that addition works
for us and the other instructions work
very similarly i can change this to sub
and what that will do is it will do the
result um r2 equals r0 minus r1
and then we can also do multiply
and what that will do is it will do r0
times r1 the main thing to keep in mind
here is that r0 is always the first
operand and then r1 is always the second
operand which only really matters in
subtraction right in addition and
multiplication the order doesn't really
matter but in subtraction it does right
and you can see that when we take 5 and
subtract it from 7 in this example here
we would clearly get a negative number
right we'd get negative 2 as our result
and that's where the interesting ideas
start to come in with our arithmetic
operations
so if i were to do this right now we can
see that i get 5 and 7 and when i
subtract them i get this big number here
or this big looking number here
and when i convert this to decimal
signed you can see i get negative 2
right but if we're looking at it in
hexadecimal it isn't really necessarily
clear
because um the reason why it's not
necessarily clear is because we could
have had a very large number in r0 and
maybe a small number in r1 and when i
subtract them i would get potentially
this very large number here
so the question is is this a very large
number or is it a negative number
there's some overlap there right because
of the way that we store negative
numbers in assembly we don't necessarily
know right off the bat if this is a
negative number i mean i clearly know
now because i put in 5 and 7 and i know
that subtracting those two gives me a
negative number but think for a minute
if we had say a user input and we
subtracted two numbers that the user
gave us how do we know if they gave us a
very large number or a negative number
right how do we know the difference
between those and just to sort of maybe
drive this point home i'll just show you
what i mean by it could have been a very
large number if i were to put this as um
as a hex right so i can say um
let's say one two three four five six
seven eight so we'll do all fs like that
and then i would have to subtract um one
from that right
and we'll just change around this ring
so that it's the first one well actually
no we can keep it like that because we
want to do r0 minus r1
so what i mean by it could have been a
large number is when i have this result
here and i subtract it from this number
here you see the result is the exact
same right we get this all f's and then
the e at the end so you can see if i
take this big number and subtract one
from it i get this but also
if i take five and i subtract it from
seven like we did before we get the same
results
so this is why there's the question of
well is it a negative number or is it a
very large number subtracted from a very
small number and the way that we solve
this problem is using the cpsr register
which is uh this register right here
you'll notice some of these letters
along here the n the z the c v i all
these sort of letters um each of these
indicate a specific flag that is set in
this register
the n for instance stands for negative
so it will tell you if the result of the
last operation was a negative number and
that's exactly what we want right we
want to set that flag so that we can
understand that this result is negative
and i can do other things too it can
take care of them if there was a carry
in the operation if there was an
overflow if the result was zero and that
sort of idea there
so
how do we get that to actually set
because if you notice when i compile and
load this and i step through these
instructions nothing happens to the cpsr
register
the answer is that we have to use a
special type of instruction
called a in this case i'll call it an
arithmetic with flags and the way that
it's represented is we just add an s to
the end of our instructions so sub s in
this case so sub s is going to set the
flags in the cpsr register
and you might be thinking well why
doesn't it just always do this why
doesn't the subtraction operation just
always set the cpsr register
and the answer is because to set the
cpsr register requires at least one
additional operation right it requires
us to actually load data into that
register and that you know adds a little
bit of overhead to the operation if we
don't need to do that then we shouldn't
so that's why there's two separate
instructions for this because um one of
them is slightly more efficient than the
other and slight efficiencies do matter
when you're programming at such a low
level
so then the second question that you
might ask is well when should i use sub
s over sub and the answer is you should
use sub s if one you know that there's
going to be negative numbers or two you
don't know what the values that are
going to be subtracted are
that means you're loading them from some
location that you don't have control
over if you're just taking two constant
numbers and subtracting them from each
other and you know what the result is
going to be then you can use you know
whatever instruction is appropriate if
it's gonna be positive just use sub
that's okay um if you don't know then
you should use sub s so you can check to
see if it's positive or negative
so just demonstrate what this ends up
doing when i compile and load this
like i said before when we do this now
you see that this cpsr register has
changed and you can see that n is now
bolded that means that it has identified
that the result was a negative number
rather than a positive one and that's
exactly what we were looking for
now just to know the reason why this bit
is set to eight is because um so each of
the four bits at the beginning of the
cpsr register um stands for one of the
flags and that's the same with every bit
every single bit is one of the flags so
since it's set to one zero zero zero
that means the negative is set to one
which means that it was negative and
then i think that the other four or the
other three zeros are the zero the carry
and the overflow which are all set to
zero and that's why they're grayed out
here
so that's the way that those flags are
actually set so if you're not working in
an emulator you'll just see that set as
eight rather than seeing the end
highlighted the end being highlighted is
nice for when you're learning because
obviously that tells you hey it's a
negative number um but if you're doing
this just like on like a linux system or
something like that you won't see that
you'll just see the eight instead so
it's it's good to understand exactly
what that's doing as well
so that would be the idea of our
arithmetic operations now there's one
other additional arithmetic operation
that is quite helpful for us and it's
the fact that um when we add two numbers
together in some instances you might end
up with a carry
and basically what that means is that
the number was way too big to actually
be stored inside of a single register so
to give you an example
if you have like um you know something
like this
and you want to add it to maybe
something like this right so we'll just
say um we'll add this and this is
another example where you would want to
use um something that actually sets the
flags and the reason being is because
when you do this addition
you'll notice that when you add these
numbers together it's far too big to
actually be stored in one register
because it overflows beyond 32 bits
right so you'll see when you do this it
actually sets the um the carry flag in
here to indicate that there was a carry
that happened in this operation
so these are the sorts of operations
where you would end up with potentially
a carry right
so when these sorts of things happen we
want to be able to catch them as we did
here but we may also want to use that
carry at some point later on
so if we want to add a carry operation
then what we need to do is we need to
use the adc
operation what this will do is it will
add a carry to a result
and what i mean by that is basically so
if we were doing this um this operation
here the result would be r2 equals r0
plus
r1
plus the carry
so the carry will basically be a one if
this flag is set equal to one
or it will be a zero otherwise so that's
the way that this works so it's either
set to zero if the carry is not set or
it's set to one if the carry flight is
set
so that's the way this adc operation
works and there are other ones as well
so we can subtract as well
using the same sort of idea we can also
multiply with the carry but the most
common one would be the add which would
be a dc like this
so this gives you an idea of some of the
fundamental arithmetic operations and
we'll see these as we discuss other
assembly programs but this just gets you
familiarized with how we add subtract
and multiply numbers and some of the
little quirks of setting flags when we
do these different types of operations
in this video we're going to take a look
at basic logical operators in arm so
these are operators such as and or
exclusive or and negation that are used
to complete bitwise operations on
registers
we're going to take a look at how these
operators work and in addition to that
i'll show you a few basic things that we
can do with these operators aside from
the typical ideas of you know comparing
if two inputs are the same or not or
those sorts of ideas
so starting off with the instructions
the and or
exclusive or they all work very
similarly to the arithmetic operators
that we saw in the previous video and by
that i mean so for instance if we were
going to do an and we would have the
destination for the results and then two
things that are being added together so
that's the way that our and operator
will typically work
so for example if i were to do like a
simple um let's move uh
and let's move it to r0 with value ff
let's move into r1 the value
22 for instance
and let's and those two together and
store the result inside of r2
when we compile and load this you'll see
that what we get is we get the two f's
here
and this one we get 16 and then the
result of adding those together is 16 of
course because all of the inputs in the
first one are all ones so wherever the
ones match up we get one wherever these
zeros match up we get zero and that
gives us the exact same result back so
you can see that that works the same way
that we would expect any typical logical
and to work
so this would be the idea of our and
now we can also do an and that sets
flags using and s so i just always want
to note that with these instructions
typically there's always a complementary
version that will set flags as well
most commonly you're going to see just
and being used since we don't usually
have flags getting set with the and
operation it's mostly just a matter of
completing the logical operation and
storing the results
that gives us our and instruction our or
instruction is similar it's orr for or
so just keep in mind it's not or it's or
with two hours
so again just to demonstrate how this
works
you can see that our two inputs are f
and 16. and we order those together we
get f
because of course anywhere that there's
a one we end up with a one and since f
and f is all ones we always end up with
ones which gives us the ff as our
results
so that gives us our or operation
and then finally our exclusive or is eor
so this is exclusive or
so just to show how this works we have
the ff the 16 when we do those together
we get e9 remember that an exclusive or
is going to only give us a one if one of
the inputs is a one not both of them
right if both of them are the same we
get a 0 otherwise we get a 1 and that's
our exclusive or
so you see that when we do this we get
exactly that result as expected
so those are the very basic logical
operations they're very simple and
straightforward there's nothing
particularly special or interesting
about them
the one that's a little bit different
actually is negation and that's one that
i want to talk about now
so with negation we do something
slightly different than just doing like
a knot on the actual register itself you
might expect that it might have like a
not operation that does that negation
that's not the case in um an arm
what we have instead is we have a
special instruction called move negative
mvn like this
what move negative does is it moves from
the source the negation of the source
into the destination so it negates the
source and then puts that result into
the destination so it does a move and a
negation at the same time
so to demonstrate that let's just do
this with r0 and itself what this will
do is it will move our zero it will
negate it and put it back in the
register that we started with
when we do this you see that we start
off with all f's and we negate it we get
zeros in the first two bits and f's and
all of the later bits now this might
seem maybe a little bit strange but
remember when we do a negation it
negates the whole register
not just like the single bits or
anything like that it does it to the
whole register
now when we have something like this
happen we might want to make it so that
the other registers are set back to zero
and the question is how would we do
something like that
and well actually we can use our and
operator to do something like that right
what we could do is we could do an and
throwing the result in r0 taking r0 and
anding it with something that we know is
going to give us zeros for those first
six bits or those first six hex values
right
which would be zero x one two three four
five six and then the others would be ff
to keep whatever is inside of them this
will clear all of these bits because
ending zero with anything gives us zero
and since these are always one if we add
anything with them we'll get back what
we started with right either a zero or a
one depending on what the value actually
is and now the result of this is we
start with the ff we negate it and then
you can see when we do the end it clears
all the other bits giving us this result
back
i know this might become a little bit
more clear if i use like um let's do a a
for instance when i do a a for an
example you see that we get five five
here rather than zeros you see that when
we clear it we keep the five five and
get rid of everything else
that's something that we can use and to
be able to do is clear specific bits in
a register so that's one of the
applications of and
so this gives you a very basic overview
of the different types of logical
operators that exist in arm this is of
course very high level and just like
very simple examples right i just want
to get you an idea of the instructions
an idea of what they might be useful for
and then from there we can continue to
build on top of those concepts so this
gives you the very fundamentals of the
logical operations and then in future
videos we'll see how they might be used
in more practical sorts of applications
in this video we're going to start to
discuss logical shifts as well as
logical rotations
and these two instructions are really
useful in the sense that they allow us
to manipulate numbers at a bit level by
way of shifting everything to the left
or to the right
and it has a lot of unique and
interesting properties that are actually
really useful to take advantage of so
what i'm going to do in this video is
it's easier to look at this as a bit
level operation rather than with hex or
decimal so i'm going to demonstrate to
you what it looks like from a binary
perspective and then in the next video
we'll actually take a look at some
examples with instructions in arm so
this is just going to get you that basic
foundation of what is a shift what is a
rotation what does it look like what
does it represent why do we use it so
that's going to be the main goal here
so we'll start off with shifts
with shifts there's two different types
of shifts that we see there's a logical
shift to the left and a logical shift to
the right
and these two differ based on what
direction the bits in the binary number
are shifting in
so to give you a basic example let's
just pick a binary number let's say 1 0
1 0 this is 10 in decimal
so when we look at this number when
we're doing a logical shift to the left
what that means is that i'm going to
move everything one position to the left
of where it started
so this zero moves over here with this
one used to be this one moves over here
where the zero used to be the zero moves
to the one and remember since there's
eight bits i didn't write them in here
but there's you know eight bits of space
here available the one is going to move
over here to this empty bit that didn't
used to have anything in it
now the actual result of this is the
following we get one zero one zero and
then there's an extra zero at the end
now when we take a look at this binary
number we actually see a really
interesting property come up and that's
the fact that this is actually equal to
20 when you translate it to decimal and
notice that this is exactly double what
we started
it's like we multiplied the value by two
and it turns out that isn't coincidental
that it's true for every single instance
of a logical shift to the left it's the
same as multiplying the value by two
as such a logical shift to the left
actually represents a fast way to do
multiplication by two and that's the
main value of doing this logical shift
now there are other reasons why we might
want to do it but this is one that's
very obvious and prevalent so this is
something that we could take advantage
of
so this would be the idea of your
logical shift to the left
now when we take a look at a logical
shift to the right it does something
very similar but in the opposite
direction right
so we start off with one zero one zero
which again is equal to ten if i shift
everything to the right it would mean
that this one shifts over here where
this zero used to be the zero shifts
over to the one the one shifts over to
the zero and then we just get rid of the
zero at the end right so this zero just
gets it disappears right so we don't
really care about it anymore
um another thing that i'll just note
here quickly remember there's
technically zeros to the left of this
right so this zero here moves into the
business where this one used to be
the result of this is the following we
get 0 1 0 1
and what is this equal to well this is
equal to four and one which makes five
notice that this is exactly half of what
we started with so it turns out that
when we shift to the right it's the same
as dividing by two so remember that we
didn't really have a way to divide
numbers before there wasn't really a
division operation in arm
this is a way that we can implement
division we can do divisions by two
which allows us to be able to actually
do full division operations
so this allows us to have division and
again there's other
reasons that we might want to do shifts
to the right or shifts to the left but
these are the two most obvious ones that
are really valuable to know about
and just in case you're really wondering
like why is this true you can you can
intuitively figure out why this ends up
multiplying by two right if you think
about what shifting to the left really
does is it increases the power of all of
the powers of two here by one which is
the same as multiplying by two whereas
this one decreases all of them by one
which is the same as dividing by two so
there is actually an intuitive reason
behind that if you want to go through
and actually sort of like derive why
this is true
so that gives you an intuition behind
logical shifts and hopefully it gives
you a bit of an understanding of why we
care about them and what they are useful
for
the next thing that we'll talk about is
a rotation which is r o r
and a rotation only really differs from
a
shift in one single way and that is that
when we talked about the shift to the
right i said okay this zero we just get
rid of it right so the right most thing
we just get rid of it we don't care
about it anymore with the rotation that
doesn't happen the rightmost thing
actually loops back over to the leftmost
position
so let me show you an example of that
suppose that we have the following so
i'll do all eight bits this time
and suppose we have something like this
so first off if i did a logical shift to
the right what you would end up with is
you would end up with you know we have
all the zeros here and then we have zero
remember everything shifts over to the
right one so we would get zero zero one
zero this would be a logical shift to
the right in this case right
now if we were to do a rotation what we
end up with instead is we end up with
this we end up with one zero zero zero
zero zero one zero notice that this one
moved to the front rather than just
getting eliminated so this gives you the
difference between the logical shift and
the rotation
now you might ask why would we want to
use a rotation
the uses of a rotation are actually a
lot more abstract than a shift
when we're dealing with rotations we're
typically using it for things like
hashing we use it for crypto we use it
for graphics um it's not an entirely
common operation to see it's typically
actually left in for historical reasons
and one thing that you'll notice because
of this is that arm doesn't actually
have a rotation to the left like an rol
this does not exist
so we can only rotate to the right
if you want to do a rotation to the left
you can technically do it with rotation
to the right
so if you want to shift n bits to the
right what you would do is you would do
sorry if you want to shift end bits to
the left rather
what you would do is you would do a
rotation to the right
32 minus n times
and you know you could sort of play
around with that and see that it
actually is true what that does is it
rotates over to the left hand side
rather than the right hand side
but again these sorts of operations the
rotations are not very commonly used we
don't see them all that much so they're
sort of just something that i'm adding
in here to say hey these exist there are
some applications of them in hashing and
crypto and graphics you might see them
at some point but
they aren't entirely common but this is
how they work just in case you ever do
see them
so it should give you a good groundwork
foundation for logical shifts and
logical rotations
in the next video we're going to
actually go through and see how we can
implement these things in our arm
assembly emulator
in this video we're going to take a look
at how logical shifts and rotations are
actually used in arm so we're actually
going to take a look at some practical
examples and see how these instructions
actually work
and be able to demonstrate that they do
actually do as i said multiplying by two
and dividing by two and make sure that
these results are actually truthful
so to start off with let's look at a
very simple example we'll do something
similar to what we did in the previous
video where we were working on the
binary numbers so what we did was we had
10 and we did some shifts on it so we
did some shifts to the right some shifts
to the left and we'll take a look at
what those results end up being
so to start off with i'm going to go
ahead and move the value 10 into
register 0.
[Music]
once we have done this what we're going
to do is we're going to do
let's do a logical shift to the left to
start off with so the way that we do
this is we do lsl
we type in the register that we want to
shift
and then we're going to indicate how
many times we want to shift
so what i was demonstrating in the video
previous was that we could shift one
time to the left and if we shift one
time to the left it was the same as
multiplying by two
with arm we can actually specify to
shift multiple times if we want to and
the way to think about that is that it's
the same as just multiplying by two
repeated amount of times
so if i shift to the left twice what i'm
doing is i'm multiplying by two twice or
multiplying by four
right if i shift three times that i
would be multiplying by two three times
right so that's the idea of what we're
looking at when we're saying how many
times we would like to shift
so if i want to shift everything to the
left one time which would be the same as
multiplying by two i simply indicate
that here
now something that's interesting about
this is that you can actually use this
to shift by a variable amount right so i
could put in like a register like r1 and
say shift by the number of times that's
inside of the register r1 right so
there's ways of being able to combine
this together to be able to utilize like
a variable amount of shifting so that's
one thing that you're able to do that i
just want to note here
so with that being said let's take a
look at what this actually does
so we compile and load the first load is
going to put 10 inside of this register
and we're going to go ahead and change
this to decimal just that way we can see
it a bit easier so you can see that we
have 10 here the next time that we move
through we do our shift which changes it
to 20 and as you can see it does as i
said it would it multiplies it by two
and just to continue on with this we'll
go ahead and do a rotation to the right
and just um we'll do a shift to the
right rather and see what that ends up
doing
now what i'm anticipating this is going
to do is it's going to shift to the
right by 1 bringing us back to 10
and let's just see if that actually does
happen so we'll go ahead and compile one
load
we start at 10 we end up at 20 the next
shift brings us back to 10.
so you can see that generally this is
working the way that we expect it to so
this is nice and simple nothing too
complicated here
now one thing that we can do is shifting
that's quite interesting and unique is
that we can combine it with the move
operator to do a move and a shift at the
same time this is a really useful sort
of thing to be able to do to give you an
example maybe i don't want to shift r0
maybe i want to store the result of
multiplying r0 by 2 into register r1
so just to demonstrate what that would
look like currently with the recurrent
instruction set i'll just go ahead and
get rid of this line
what i'm saying i want to do is i want
to
move
you know r
into r1 the value r0
and what i want to do is i want to do is
shift on r1 by one
so what i'm doing is i'm preserving the
value of r0 right so that way the value
of r 0 doesn't actually change r1 stores
that value instead
now rather than having to do the move
and shift in separate instructions we
can actually do them together
so what i can do is i can add on a third
piece here
i could say lsl
1 just like this
what this is going to do is it's going
to move the value stored in r0 into r1
and then it's going to shift it by one
so let's take a look at what happens so
we get 10 and you can see we get 20
directly so you can see that it does
that shift immediately right so we don't
have to worry about it happening you
know multiple times right we don't have
to do it in multiple separate
instructions we could do it all in one
instruction instead so this is something
sort of unique about the shifts that we
haven't seen with other sorts of
instructions so far
so that shows you how the logical shifts
work inside of arm i'm going to end off
here just by showing you a rotation just
that way you're able to see what that
ends up looking like
so the instruction for rotation is of
course ror like we said
[Music]
and of course we could do some examples
of shifting by one for instance um
although we should pick a number that
will actually flow over into the the
remaining you know ends that it goes
over to the left hand side
let's see i think our value perhaps like
um well value like 15 should definitely
do it right because we don't have all
ones on the right hand side so let's go
ahead and give that a try and see what
happens
we get 15 and you see when we overflow
over we get this massive number here
this one it actually helps to look at
the hex to see what ends up happening
right so you can see that we have eight
as our first hex value which is one zero
zero zero so you can see that the one
shifted over to the front we still have
seven on the right hand side which
implies that we have you know all of the
ones remaining except for the one that
was on the end right we have zero one
one one and then on the other hand we
have one zero zero zero on the left hand
side so you can see how this rotation is
generally working it is doing sort of
the idea of what i was saying would
happen with it
so this gives you an idea of how the
rotations work and i want to note as
well that you could do the same thing
with rotations that we did with um with
moving right um we can put it into the
move instruction and we can rotate as
loyal as the move right so the same sort
of idea is what we did with these shifts
before
so this demonstrates to you how
rotations and shifts work in arm so you
now understand what these operations do
what their value is and how the
instructions can be used in arm next
video we'll take a look at some other
instructions through arm and we can get
a better understanding of some more
advanced things that we can do with this
programming language
now that we understand some of the basic
instructions in arm we can start to take
a look at some of the typical high-level
constructs that we would see and find
out how they map generally into the
assembly language and the way that we're
going to start with this is by taking a
look at statements related to
conditionals these would be statements
sort of like if statements in higher
level languages we want to take
instructions based on the result of
something else that has happened in the
program already perhaps something
related to a user input or something of
the sort and we want to be able to take
different paths based on the values that
are provided so in this video i'm going
to give you some really basic examples
of how this can be done
so the main way that we do these
branching instructions is using
comparators and branches
so a comparator is something that allows
us to compare two values to determine
whether or not they are greater than
less than or equal to each other
branches on the other hand allow us to
move around our program to different
locations based on the result of
comparisons
so for example we might want to move to
a different part of the program if a
result is greater than another or maybe
if two results are equal we move to a
different location in the program this
is very similar to the way that if
statements and else statements work in
your typical programming languages
so let's take a look at a really simple
example i'm gonna go ahead and move some
values into some registers we'll do some
comparisons and see generally how these
branches actually work
so let's move it to r0 the value 1.
i'm going to move 2 into r1 and now i'm
going to do a comparison between these
two values the way that we do this is we
use cmp that's our comparison
instruction
and then we give it two arguments and
i'll discuss how this generally works
once we've got it written out here
so what a comparison is really doing is
it's going to take a look at r0 and r1
and it's going to do the following
computation
it's going to do r0 minus r1 so it's
going to subtract the two from each
other
why does it do this because this is a
way of comparing two values we know that
if r0 is bigger than r1 then the result
of this will be some positive number if
r0 is smaller than r1 the result would
be some negative number and if they're
the same as each other of course the
result is going to end up being zero
so we can know those three results based
on the subtraction of the numbers
so what happened is the computation for
the compare will do this subtraction and
what will happen is this cpsr register
this one right here is going to get set
based on the results of the subtraction
now as we've briefly discussed in the
cpsr register we can set different
things like negative zero carry overflow
and these sorts of flags
well it turns out that that's very
useful for this situation because
suppose if we subtract these two numbers
and i want to see if r0 is smaller than
r1 if r0 is smaller than r1 i expect to
get some negative number and that would
mean that the negative flag should get
set in the cpsr register so you see how
all this sort of fits together we've
sort of put the puzzle together and we
can see how we can use all of these
different pieces to get our conditional
statements so this is a very high level
construct that we're able to replicate
in assembly for that matter when you
compile your high-level languages it's
using this sort of idea in the
background maybe not exactly like this
but similar sorts of ideas to this
so understanding that what happens after
we do this comparison
well in this case maybe we want to check
to see if um so let's say we want to
check to see if r0 is bigger than r1 so
we want to see if it's greater than r1
what we can do is we can use a branch
greater than which is written as bgt
so it's b is branch and then g t is
greater than
and what we do is we give this a
location and the location is going to be
some label now we did also discuss
briefly the idea of labels so start is
an example of a label and we can
actually add more labels if we would
like so i can add in a label like grader
for instance
this would be the label that will run
when the branch greater than occurs so
what i can say i could say bgt
then i can see greater
what will happen is when it does this
comparison if it finds that r0 is bigger
than r1 it will move to this greater
label and it will start to execute
whatever is provided here
so in this case we'll just do something
to see that this is working um we'll
move a value into r2
so that would be an example of this now
let's go ahead and run this and just see
what ends up happening
so you can see generally that these
values actually aren't greater right r0
is not greater than r1 which means that
we shouldn't actually take this branch
here
now the question is what happens after
if we don't take this branch and the
answer is we just continue on as if we
never actually executed this instruction
so maybe make this a little bit more
clear let me add in a move instruction
inside of here
right so we can add in this move
instruction and we can see that when we
do this the comparison ends up not being
a value that's greater you can see the
negative flag is set indicating that the
subtraction was a negative number
when we do this you see that it skips
over this branch and it just moves into
the next instruction
so you can see how that generally works
now if it were greater right if i said
three for instance here and we ran this
what would end up happening is we do our
comparison
you see that we don't get a negative
number instead we actually get a carry
and this indicates the value was bigger
rather than being smaller
you'll see that we can move into this
branch for greater than you can see that
rather than moving into this instruction
it skips it and goes to this greater
label
so this gives you an idea of what's
actually happening with these branches
now generally when we're doing these
sorts of instructions it's important to
note the flow of assembly languages
if the value isn't greater than when we
have this instruction here we saw that
it moved to this instruction however
once this instruction finishes assembly
will continue moving through until it
reaches the next instruction and you can
see what ends up happening is we end up
in this greater branch anyways and that
is of course a problem we don't like
that what we want to do is we want to
skip the greater branch we want to make
sure that we don't actually reach it if
we're not greater than that value
to do this we can use branches as well
so there's a special type of branch
called a branch always b-a-l so branch
and then always
and this will always execute so we'll
always branch this location regardless
of what happens
so for b a l what i could do is i could
say rather than going to greater i can
go to a different one you know maybe
i'll call this one default
so in this case we can create a default
label and then we could do something
here so i could do the same thing as
before
right so we move 2 into r2
and we can see that in this case if we
don't reach this greater branch we move
here and we always branch to default
which skips over greater and ends up
here instead this allows us to
effectively bypass this greater
instruction now
another thing that we need to keep in
mind here is once we finish the grader
portion right we would also fall into
the default case so it's just very
important to note that the instructions
are always going to run sequentially i
want you to understand that very clearly
that everything is going to run
sequentially here right and i can show
you this right so if i compile and load
this we have three we have two we
subtract them we do the branch for
greater than we end up in this move
instruction right
so we do this move instruction and you
can see that we end up in default next
right and then it runs that instruction
so it's very important to note that it's
always going to move sequentially right
so if we don't want to go into default
after grader i should add in another
branch to move somewhere else
so this is just something to keep in
mind when you're writing these branches
everything runs sequentially that could
be a little bit tricky so just be very
careful of that stepping through the
programs is going to make it very clear
what is going on you'll understand it
completely once you step through a few
programs but just keep that in mind and
keep thinking about that as you're
writing your code and running it and
practicing with it
so this gives you a general idea of the
different branches and how they
generally work in our program now
there's of course a lot of different
branches and i'm not going to like show
off every single one of them or go into
a hefty amount of detail for them i'll
just sort of like lay out a few of them
here that are common
so if greater than and greater than or
equal to
we have less than
and less than or equal to
and then we have equals
or does not equals
those are the different branches that we
have available to us and they're fairly
intuitive in naming right eq equals any
not equals lt is less than le is less
than or equal to so on like this
you can get a whole table of these
through the arm documentation there's
actually a lot more than the ones that
i'm showing here i'm just showing you
the most basic ones that will come up
most frequently if you ever find
yourself needing a very special branch
it likely exists and you can find that
branch in the actual documentation but
this gives you the main overall picture
of what branches are commonly used how
do we use branches and what is the
effect of using the branches
so that's everything for this video in
the next video we're going to see some
applications of branching in the form of
looping so branches allow us to
implement looping and repetition as well
so we're going to take a look at this
sort of concept and be able to build
some interesting applications and
hopefully help you understand this idea
of conditionals and branching a little
bit more
in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about looping as a
consequence of the conditional
statements that we learned in the
previous video
when we discussed the idea of
conditional statements one of the big
benefits that we can get out of them is
the ability to repeat instructions of
course if we could branch to a specific
label we can always move back to a
specific starting point and repeat
instructions and we can always exit that
repetition using a comparison and some
form of branching as you would with like
a for loop or a while loop right so
you're able to get that exact sort of
idea looping while some sort of
condition is true or while some sort of
condition is not true as well as looping
a specific number of times so we can get
both of those loops working in assembly
in the same sort of way that we would in
a high level language maybe with a
little bit more finesse required to make
it actually work
so to better understand this we're going
to take a look at a relatively simple
example this is going to draw from a lot
of the things that we've learned so far
so it's going to be a great way to sort
of refresh your knowledge and apply some
of these instructions in a more
practical way
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start off by defining a list of numbers
and this number list is just like all
the numbers from one to ten so something
very simple for us
and what we're going to do is we're
going to load this list into memory and
we're going to try to iterate the list
so the first few parts that is fairly
simple right we're going to load the
list into memory using ldr
so that part is it's no big deal
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to start by loading the first
element into my into my memory i'm going
to use r1 to store the elements of the
list and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add up all of the numbers
inside of the list and i'm going to
store that result in r2 so that's sort
of the main idea of our program
so let's go ahead and do that we'll
start by loading the value of the first
value of the list into r1
of course we use that using addressing
based on the address that was placed
inside of r0
and then we can do the addition to add
that first value into r2 to sort of like
initialize everything right
so that gives us sort of like an
initialization and then we can actually
start to talk about the looping portion
of this so this starts up the list so
what we've done so far is we've sort of
set to the um the first value of our sum
equal to the first value in the list and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to iterate past that point and add
those values onto that r2 register until
we've reached the end of the list
now this creates an interesting concept
right how do we find the end of the list
well let's take a look at what it looks
like in memory
i'm going to go ahead and compile and
just step into it to find the location
on my list it's at location 10 in memory
and we can see it right here you see all
the numbers from 1 to 10.
and then afterwards we get all of these
a's repeated
now it turns out in the case of my
memory i have all a's as a
representation of an empty
slot in memory
so it goes to serve that if we have this
set of a's we've reached the end of the
list so i'm going to continue to move
through the list iterating until i reach
something that is equal to
this now how we do that check is
actually a little bit complicated we
actually have to do something sort of
interesting here now when we work with
assembly you might think okay well
that's easy i can just compare you know
that value and then we'll be done but
the way that assembly specifically arm
assembly handles literals is a little
bit weird so when we have those
immediate values or literals they can
only be a specific size and i believe
that size is typically two hex values
so if we have something bigger than two
hex values we have to be a little bit
more creative with how we deal with this
and the main way that we're gonna deal
with this is we're going to use
constants and contents isn't something
that we've really talked about so far
but they're very simple
at the very top of our program we're
going to define our constant using a
keyword that is dot e-q-u
so equ like this
similar to defining our list we're going
to give this a name and a value
and i'm just going to go ahead and copy
it because i don't want to
mess it up here so just copy this over
and place that there
and there you have it that is our
constant defined so this defines a
constant called end list and it gives it
a value which is this value here
and then we can load this into memory
using an ldr like we've done with the
with the list loading it it's going to
load this into r3 just have it available
to us
so there we have this value now loaded
into r3 and now we can actually do our
loop so i'm going to start by creating a
label for our loop
and what our loop is going to do is it's
going to load the next value in the list
so what this will do is it will
increment by four and then it will load
the value of that address into r1
and then it's going to take a look at
this value and see if it is equal to
that location in memory that is empty so
this all these a's here so remember we
stirred that in r3 so we're going to
compare
r1 to r3
if those are equal to each other we want
to leave the loop so i'm going to say bq
exit i'm going to put a label exit here
the label exit isn't going to do
anything it's just going to be the exit
point of this loop
alternatively if we have not reached the
end of the list what i'm going to do is
i'm going to add the value
into r2
and then i'm going to loop again so i'm
going to branch to the top of the loop
so to understand this what's going to
happen is it's going to load the next
value in the list
if that value is equal to the end of the
list so this set of memory that
sort of is uninitialized then we're
going to go to the exit otherwise we're
going to add that value to the total and
then we're going to loop again
now this isn't the only way that we
could find the end of the list we could
know the length of the list that could
be another way that we might be able to
do this and there are likely other
tricks that work in assembly to be able
to do this however mostly when we have
the length of the list it makes things a
little bit easier for us to be able to
do there's an interesting idea of
uninitialized memory it can be a little
bit unpredictable right we don't
necessarily know these values are going
to be stored this way so the way that
i'm doing it right now is a simple
example that's going to demonstrate to
you the idea of looping
in the real world when we're doing this
it's a little bit more complicated what
we would end up doing is we would end up
putting a special value at the end of
this list you know something predictable
and then when it loads into memory we
know what value is at the end of the
list
i can actually give you a practical
example of this if you're familiar with
c programming you'll know that
characters and strings have a special
value at the end of it and it's this
backslash zero character it's called the
null terminator what this is doing is
it's indicating the end of the list so
that when we iterate we know where to
stop
so that's just to give you a bit more of
a practical idea of how we do this but
for now we'll assume that we're in this
perfect world where uninitialized memory
stays put and we don't have to worry
about that but just in case you're
curious about that that would be the way
that we would usually handle this sort
of idea
so with that out of the way let's just
talk about what this program does let's
go ahead and execute it
so you can see that we get the location
into memory
we then load in that end location so we
can check for it
we then start by loading the first value
which is the value one and we add that
onto the total
now we get into the looping so you can
see the next value is two we check if
that's the end of the list it's not so
we add that value to the total and then
we go back to the top and then we
continue doing that and you'll see that
this continues on for a while right so
we're going to do this for every single
value inside of the list it will just
keep looping through right we're at 7
8
9
and 10.
and once you reach 10 you'll see that
the next value is going to be that end
of the list all of the a's there
so at this point we compare them we see
that they are equal to each other and
you see that it skips this out to the
exit rather than adding it to the total
and looping again
so this point we've exited the loop
everything is done we've iterated the
list and you can see that the value that
we got at the end was 55 which is the
value of adding 1 to 10 inclusive
and that's the way that we set up our
loops
so using this sort of concept you could
do all sorts of different loops you
could do for loops you could do while
loops and you know you're able to sort
of expand your knowledge from here this
gives you the basic fundamentals it
shows you how you can use the branching
for the loops and from here you can
apply this in many different ways
whenever looping is actually required
so that's everything for this video in
the next few videos we'll take a look at
some other instructions that we're able
to use related to this idea of sort of
structuring our program through
conditionals and looping and see
different ways that we can manage this
sort of idea
so in this video we're just going to
discuss some of the fundamentals of
conditional instructions now conditional
instructions allow us to be able to
complete a specific instruction based on
a condition so similar to the
comparisons that we saw with branches
what we're able to do is we're able to
do a comparison and then specify to do
another operation based on the result of
that comparison without the need to
branch around the program or do anything
complicated like that so it allows us to
create a more
condensed form of our branching
exercises that we were looking at in the
previous few videos
so let's discuss a little bit about this
with an example so suppose that i were
to move some values into registers so
we'll just move some random values it
doesn't really matter what they
are so i'll move two into r0 and maybe
we'll move forward to r1
now we'll do is we'll compare r0 and r1
and of course we know that the result of
this comparison is that r0 is less than
r1 right because if we subtract 2 from 4
we get a negative number
now in this case maybe i want to add 1
to register 2 if the result of this was
actually less than
if we wanted to do this in the previous
videos with the knowledge that we had
what we would do is we would do
something like this we would say okay we
would branch less than um
we could call it like add r2 and then we
would have like an add r2 that would do
exactly that it would add to
the register um
r2
the value 1 right
so that would be the idea of what we
could do in order to achieve that effect
and then we would have to have a branch
over here to skip over it just in case
um you know we didn't actually want to
do that right just in case it wasn't
less than then we could skip over it and
say like maybe skip over to like an exit
and that would be
you know over here
so this would be the way that we would
have done this before with just branches
right and this is not bad but there's a
lot of lines of code for this specific
instruction and really it doesn't
require as much like of this code as
what we really want right so we can
condense this a little bit more using
these conditional instructions so the
way that these conditional instructions
work is that with things like add you
can add on a condition so i can say add
lt what that means is add less than so
what will happen is this instruction
will only trigger if the comparison that
came previous
is less than so if r0 is less than r1 in
this case
then we will do this addition
instruction so like i was saying before
we'll try adding 1 to r2
and let's just see what ends up
happening right so we can compile and
load
we see that we get 2 and four into those
registers when we do our comparison you
see that the negative flag gets set in
the cpsr register that tells us that the
value was less than right so two is less
than four
and now we come up to this add
instruction and it should only add one
to r2
if the value of the previous comparison
was less than
and we see that it does add 1 because
the value was less than
so you could see that generally this is
how this instruction tends to work right
and there are other variations of this
instruction it's not just add that we
can do this with we could do this with a
lot of the different instructions in arm
so there's things like um like
subtraction and multiplication we could
do with the move instruction as well so
just to give you like another example we
could do something like um this like
move
greater than or equal to
uh the value 5 into r2 right
this would only trigger if the value was
greater than or equal so you could see
when we run this and we go through our
instructions it doesn't actually do
anything because the value was not
greater than or equal
so the move instruction doesn't execute
so that'll be an example of you know
whether it will execute or not and of
course we can flip this around to be
able to get it to execute there's two
different ways to do that we can move a
bigger number to r0 or we can flip this
comparison right
if i flip this comparison it now does r1
minus r0 so 4 minus 2 that's a greater
than or equal to value
and when we run this now you'll see that
we get 2 4 you know we do the comparison
you can see the results in the cpsr
register will result in it moving 5 in
because the result was greater than or
equal to
so i just wanted to give you an idea of
these sorts of instructions just to show
that they exist in assembly just to be
able to make your code a little bit more
simple
because having to run branches all the
time is very complex we don't want to
have to do that every single time so
this allows us to reduce the complexity
of our applications overall and just
write simpler code
so that's everything for this video in
the next video we're going to dive into
the idea of functions which are a bit
more of a complicated way of doing
branching but as you probably know core
to most higher level languages is the
idea of a function so we'll dive into
more detail to get an understanding of
how functions actually work at a low
level perspective and get some
familiarity with writing functions with
arm assembly
so in this video we're going to start to
discuss the idea of functions in
assembly and specifically we're just
going to take a look at how we can call
and return to a location using these
functions so we're not going to dive
into a huge amount of detail i want to
give you sort of the higher level
functional flow of things and the
purpose of doing this is that well
functions tend to be very complicated a
lot of people approach this by showing
you the full picture immediately and we
start getting into all these complicated
register interactions and it's very hard
to understand so i want to break it down
into smaller pieces that it's a lot
easier for you to be able to grasp every
single individual concept and then we
can put it all together and really run
with it and see how things are working
with a full example
so to start off with we already know
sort of the base fundamental ideas of
calling different locations in our
program right moving around to different
labels in our application
so let me give you a really simple
example suppose that we wanted to create
a program that added two numbers
together and we wanted that to be a
function because maybe we might do it
multiple times throughout our program
well in order to do this we're going to
go ahead and start by moving some values
into some registers that we want to be
added
and really you can make these values
whatever you want i'll just move into r0
and r1
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to branch off to a function that's
going to add the numbers together and
we're going to call that add 2.
so we'll call it add2
and then i'll define it here
and all this is going to do is it's just
going to add the numbers together and
store the result in r2
and there we have a very simple idea of
a function
so when we run this of course it should
work the way that we expect it to right
we get one a three we branch over to our
add function it adds the numbers
together we end up with four and
everyone is happy
now my question to you is what if i
wanted to do something slightly
different
what if i wanted to continue execution
directly after this function call so
what i mean by that is that maybe after
this function call i want to do
something different right i want to you
know move some more numbers into
registers you know maybe i want to like
move into r3 the value 4 right
so if i want to do this i have to have
some way of coming back to this location
after this function is called
now there are a few ways that we could
achieve this sort of idea right like i
showed in a previous video what we could
do is we could branch after this ad and
we could branch to this location here
and then after that location we can
branch beyond the the add to function so
we don't actually run back into it
this creates a little bit of complexity
and we don't really like that complexity
it's a little bit weird to follow so in
these sorts of situations where we're
just calling this as a function what we
can do is we can add in what is called a
return address and with the return
address what we're able to do is we're
able to return to the function where we
started so we're able to at the end of
this function return back to the
location directly after we called that
function
so this is the idea of a return
so that's what we're going to take a
look at here we're going to take a look
at how we can do this and the first
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to change this branch to a bl
which means branch linked
and what that's going to do is it's
going to store the location that follows
this branch inside of one of our
registers which is this one here the lr
register or link register
so without doing anything further let me
just show you what that looks like
so when we go to this point here bl
you'll see that lr gets 0 0 0 0 0 and
then c right
what that location corresponds to is the
address of the instruction that follows
the branch so you can see here at c
there's this move instruction which is
right after our branch
so you can see that what this link
register stores is it stores the
location directly after the call or
branch to the
function so in order to make this work
after we finish this here we should go
back to the location that's stored
inside of the link register
so in order to do this we can use
another instruction known as a bx
this will branch back
to the location stored in register so in
this case we can branch back to lr which
will branch us back to the link register
so let's pull that all together and
let's see what that looks like
when we do this we move the values into
our registers we branch into the add
function you can see that it's storing c
as our return location which is this
move instruction right after this branch
you'll see that we add the values
together in r2 and then when we branch
it takes us back to this move
instruction so you can see that that
actually worked it brought us back to
the location where we started
this mimics this sort of flow of a
typical function right if you are
familiar with higher level languages
when you have a function you have a
return the return takes you back to
where you started this is the exact same
idea and this is what your higher level
languages are doing in the background
when it translates into assembly this
would be the idea of what is happening
with that translation
so this gives you a bit of an intuition
behind how we actually do these branches
with returns now
i'm excluding a little bit of detail
here there's more things that need to
happen to make this work completely
functionally right um you know if we
have more complex programs there's
certain safeguards that we need to take
in order to make this like as as good as
possible however for the time being you
have a good understanding of branching
with the links how that link register
works and how to return back afterwards
so that's all we're going to talk about
in this video this gives you the
fundamental ideas of functions and
subroutines with returns and now in the
next video i'm going to discuss a little
bit more detail of how we can say
preserve things before we move into
these functions and then be able to
utilize that to our advantage so that's
what we'll sort of go into next after
this video
so one notable idea about functions and
subroutines is that they often have to
do calculations inside of them in order
to get the result that we're looking to
get in order to do these various
calculations we may need to use
different registers in our processor
now the number of registers that we have
in arm are of course limited we don't
have an infinite number of registers to
work with so because of this we may need
to reuse a register inside of a function
that's already being used outside of the
function
in these sorts of situations we need to
be able to preserve what we had before
we called the function and then be able
to restore it once we're done with the
function
you can think of this concept similar to
local variables in the function when we
declare a local variable in the function
its scope is to live inside of the
function once we read the function we no
longer need that variable so the
variable is just deallocated and a
garbage collector will come and you know
remove the memory and all of that fun
stuff
so what we're doing here is we're
emulating that sort of idea we're going
to allocate some registers in our main
sort of aspect of our program we're
going to call our function we're going
to use the same registers then we're
going to restore the values back to the
main
this is done in the background in high
level level applications typically the
compiler is responsible for setting up
these sort of register allocations so
this is something that we would see in
sort of the low-level assembly that
comes out of compiling a program so it's
something that is done by your
high-level languages without you really
knowing about it
so let's take a look at the details of
this so suppose that we have a function
where you know some stuff was happening
beforehand and then we call a function
and then we continue on as normal
afterwards so maybe some of the stuff
that was happening beforehand is using
the registers r0 and r1 maybe they have
some values inside of them so let's say
you know r0 has the value of one
let's say r1 has the value of three
now what's going to happen is we're
going to do a branch for a function i'm
just going to call the function get
value
and then we'll go ahead and create that
function so we'll say get a value
and what this function is going to do is
it's going to need to use r0 and r1
we'll just pretend all the registers are
full right now and r0 and r1 are the
only ones that we can really work with
so
let's suppose that we're going to use
those two so we're going to say we're
going to move some values into our zero
uh we're going to move some values into
r1
and then we're going to do some sort of
calculation so i'll just add the two
together perhaps and store the result in
r2 and then we'll return back to the
link register and we're done
so in this situation you can see quite
clearly that when we move into this
function
r0 and r1 are overwritten right so i've
got to compile and load this right now
you know we would have one and three
then when we branch we get five and
seven
we do our calculation but when we come
back to the beginning of our function we
no longer have these results available
to us right we no longer have the r0 and
r1 values
so to be able to help resolve that what
we're going to do is something
interesting here what we're going to do
is we're going to push the values of r0
and r1 onto the stack memory so we're
going to do this we're going to say push
r0 r1
what this is going to do is it's going
to place the values of r0 and r1 onto
our stack right
so it's going to place them onto the
stack and then what's going to happen is
once we're done doing everything related
to this function we're going to go ahead
and pop them off the stack like this
we're going to say pop r0
and r1
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to i'm just going to branch
into like an end label so we can just
sort of like get somewhere that isn't
going to have um you know the function
interfering with it because otherwise we
just move right into the function again
and that would be the end of this so
what's happening here is when we move
the values into r0 and r1 we then push
them onto the stack memory so we'll get
pushed over here onto stack memory
somewhere um and then what's gonna
happen after that is we're gonna call
this function we overwrite r0 and r1 we
do our calculation when we return back
to the link register we come back here
and then what we do is we pop the values
off of the stack back into r0 and r1 so
it's going to pop those values and place
them back where they started this is
preserving the values of r0 and r1 on
the stack and then placing them back
when they're needed again so you can see
that the result of this is that the
values for r0 and r1 don't get
overwritten they get used locally in the
function but we don't overwrite them
permanently so let's run this and see
what happens
so you can see that we get one and three
to r0 and r1 and then we push them onto
the stack if i come over to the stack
memory here you can see we have three
and one
so when we're thinking about how popping
works just to just to sort of clarify
why we're doing this pop the way that we
are what's gonna happen is we're gonna
pop the first thing into the first
register and then the second thing into
the second register right
since the stack pointer currently points
at this you know ffff8 address what
happens is it's going to take the value
off that address which in this case is
one it's going to pop it onto the first
register which is r0 which is this one
here
and then we're gonna pop three onto r1
which is this one here right so you can
see that it just pops one after the
other like that starting at the top and
moving down to the bottom so hopefully
it helps you understand a little bit
about the ordering of these two
operations
now when we do our branch you see that
we come into here we have five in our
zero we got seven and r1 we do some
calculations with them and then we
branch back to the beginning
when we branch back to the beginning you
see that we hit this pop instruction now
watch what happens right the stack
pointer currently points at the location
of one and three right here and here
when we go ahead and run this operation
what you'll see is that r0 is now one
and r1 is three you can see that it
actually did preserve those values right
so it actually did place them back into
their respective locations
this shows that we can actually preserve
these values so they can be used in the
function and then sent back to their
original values after the function right
and of course we have our branch that
just takes us to the end
so hopefully this helps you understand
the idea of how we can preserve values
in our functions and we can use these
sorts of ideas in a lot of different
ways right
one other way that we can use this is
actually with return values right
suppose that r2 was also being used what
we could do is we could do something
like this we could say okay so push r2
onto the stack
and then we come back here we pop them
we'd currently be pointing at r2 so what
we can do is we can place it in some
unused register right so if i want to
get that return address value i could
say okay let's place it into an unused
register maybe um you know r9 is unused
for instance right so that would be able
to place us at r9 instead of having to
be you know somewhere else right so
instead of having to keep it in r2 we
can place it on the stack and then we
can retrieve it from the stack
afterwards this would be a more
traditional way of returning values
although i think often values are just
returned on the in the register itself
so we don't really have to worry about
this sort of idea because the thing is
with values being returned if you return
a value
odds are you're going to be using it at
some point in the code right at some
point soon in the code usually so what
happens is we place it into an unused
register and then we just use it right
so that's the typical case with these um
with these returns you know otherwise
you'd have to pop it off and place it
into its position immediately so you
need it in an empty register regardless
so that's why we don't usually do that i
just wanted to show you that just in
case you ever see it it is something
that you can do i think it's not usually
the case that you would end up doing
that
so with this you now have a full picture
of subroutines and functions in arm
you understand more of how to preserve
values how to set values onto the stack
and remove them from the stack and this
allows you to be able to write fully
functional subroutines for your programs
so that sort of sums up a lot of the
logical ideas of what we would typically
talk about for sort of an introduction
to arm assembly type course for the next
few videos that i put out i'm going to
be showing you the ideas of working with
hardware with the armament processor
which is actually going to be pretty
straightforward because we actually have
some hardware devices here on the right
hand side so i'm going to show you how
to interact with those hardware devices
get you familiar with hardware and then
we can start to take a look at some
other concepts maybe at a little bit of
a higher level and see how we can
interact with arm and other system
related processes so that's sort of
where we'll take the next few videos
in this video we're going to take a look
at how we can interact with a variety of
different hardware devices using our arm
processor
on the right here we have a variety of
different devices i'm just going to note
right now you need to be using the arm
de1 soc emulator to have these devices
if you're using just the arm one general
emulator you won't have these devices
available to you so you have to use the
de1 sock emulator
so with this emulator we have a number
of different hardware devices that are
available for us to be able to interact
with and i'm going to show you how to
interact with a few of these different
pieces of hardware and once you have an
idea of some of the general devices that
we're able to interact with you'll have
a better understanding of how to
interact with the other devices that are
available to you
so primarily i'm just going to show you
how to work with the leds and the
switches and these are really just a
rudimentary input and output the
switches are an input and the leds are
an output
so let me show you how the input works
first which is the switches
the very first thing that we need to do
is we actually need to declare a
variable that's going to store the
location of our switch and later our led
as well
the way that we do this is we say dot
equ
and then we put the name of the
variables so in this case i'm going to
call mine switch
and then we put the location of the
variable so in this case the location is
right here this ff
two zero zero zero four zero right here
so we're going to put that by n so we'll
put it in hex right so zero x ff
two zero zero zero four zero
now there's a good reason why we do this
the reasoning is because you can't
directly load something this large into
arm directly so you can't use an ldr and
just load in this value as a constant
value there's a limit to the size of the
constant values that are allowed to be
loaded in directly so if your value is
larger than that you actually have to
declare it as a constant value like i've
done here and then what you can do is
you can load it in like this you could
say ldr and then i can go into r0 for
instance the value of switch
and what you'll see is that when we do
this we can compile and load
and once we do that we should be able to
see the actual value oh sorry i forgot a
comma here
so don't forget the comma here so it's
eq switch comma and then the address
now everything will compile
and when we do that you can see we just
get that exact value loaded into r0 so
all we've really done is we've declared
it here as a constant and then we've
loaded it into our r0 register to be
used later on
so if i want to be able to use this
register what i have to do is i have to
be able to retrieve the value that is
located at its memory address so what's
going to happen is each of these
switches is going to correspond with a
different number and a different number
is going to be represented in binary
based on the switches that are on so
this rightmost switch here
is going to represent like the 2 to the
power of 0 portion of the binary this
one is 2 to the power of 1 this one is 2
to the power of 2 and so on like that so
that's the way that this is working if
it's on it's like a 1 in binary and if
it's off it's like a 0 in binary so for
example if i check this off it would be
the same as 1 0 in binary which is 2 of
course
so let's take a look at how that works
what we do is we say ldr i'm going to
load into r1 the value that's stored in
r0 so remember this is the address of
the switches r0 is and we're loading
from the location right r0 into r1
so let's compile and load and see what
that does you'll see that r0 is
currently equal to this memory location
when i step into the next line of code
you see that i got the value 2. and
that's because i have the 1 checked off
so remember it's 1 0 which means that
it's equal to 2.
and we can do this with all sorts of
different numbers right so i could check
off like all three of these right we
would get one one one let's just reload
it and give that a try you see that that
gives us seven right because it's four
plus two plus one which is seven of
course
so using this we can actually get inputs
from users right so i can actually do
things based on the input from these
switches right so i just put in whatever
value i want in the switch when it loads
that value then we can manipulate it as
we need so this is a very simple way to
gain input from a hardware device right
so you may have been wondering
throughout this course like how do we
actually get inputs this is one way that
we're able to do it
and then similarly how do we output
values we could do that using our leds
and the leds are going to work in a very
similar way
when we take a look at the right hand
side led the rightmost led represents
the first digit of binary and then the
second digit the third digit the fourth
digit so on and so forth like that right
so it's the same sort of idea
so let me show you what happens with
this so let's say um dot equ because i
have to declare the location of the led
right so it's gonna be led comma
zero x ff
zero
like that
so once we have that located what we're
going to do is we're going to go ahead
and
load that value into memory like we did
before but instead of loading data from
that location we're actually going to
store data in that location right
because we're using it as an output
rather than an input we're going to put
data into that memory location instead
of taking data from that memory location
so to demonstrate this let's go ahead
and load the data that we got from the
switches into the leds
so in order to do that what we're gonna
we're gonna do is this we're gonna ldr
and i'm just gonna go ahead and
overwrite r0 because i've already gotten
the data from the switches so i don't
need it anymore so let's say from r0
we're going to load in the led address
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to go ahead and store
the data that's currently in r1
into the location of r0 and the way i do
that is i say str
r1 into r0
so what this is going to do is so well
actually we could just run the program
and see what it's going to do right so
we can step in you see that the first
line loads the location of the switches
and then the second line gets the value
from the switches into register r1 right
so currently this value is b because
that's what's represented with this it's
one zero one one right so that's the
value that's in here that'd be 8 9 10 11
right which corresponds to b and hex
now once we've done this what we do next
is we load in the location of the leds
into memory which is
0
ff2000
so you can see that those two match up
with each other r0 and the led value
here
and then what we do is we store the
value that's currently in r1
into the location of r0
so when i step into this
you see what happens is the leds light
up right they light up based on the
values that we placed inside of register
r0 or r1 rather
so you could see what happened is these
are matching up with each other now the
switch matches up with the leds the
reason being is because we took the
value from the switches and stored it
into the leds
so you can see that that actually lights
those values up so we can actually
represent a binary using these leds
so this gives you a very simple
explanation towards how we can actually
work with input and output using various
different hardware devices
there's a lot of different hardware
devices that exist here right there's
push buttons there's seven segment
displays there's jtags
there's there's a lot of different ones
and really the best way to learn these
different hardware devices is just to
play around with them right there's lots
of documentation online that can tell
you information about how these hardware
devices typically work and i encourage
you to try each of these devices and
just see what they do understand them
and play around with them that'll be the
best way for you to really learn those
hardware devices i've showed you the the
very basic ways that you can interact
with them and from here you should be
able to interact with all of these
hardware devices and see what each of
them do
hello and welcome back i hope that
you're all doing well in this video
we're going to start to take a look at
the idea of programming arm through an
actual operating system in this case a
linux operating system
now the linux operating system that i'm
going to be using for these videos is
called raspbian it's a raspberry pi
based operating system and the reason
why i'm going to be using this operating
system is because the raspberry pi
computer runs an arm processor and this
actual operating system is developed
completely compatible with arm which
makes it a really good choice for us to
actually program various different arm
things on it now of course there's lots
of different operating systems that use
arm however this one is one that is
lightweight it's easy to emulate and it
will support everything that we need so
it's a pretty decent choice for our
purposes now the reason why we're
choosing to emulate these operating
systems is because i'm aware that most
people probably don't have an arm device
lying around you know raspberry pi isn't
too expensive but of course it's a
little bit much to ask someone to go out
and buy a device to learn arm assembly
um so rather than doing that i'm going
to show you how to emulate it so you can
just write it on your computer and then
at some point down the line if you want
a physical device you can go out and get
one of those knowing all of the arm
stuff that you will know from these
videos
so for the purposes of this video i'm
using virtualbox i have an ubuntu
machine it's running ubuntu 20.04 i
believe and it is a 64-bit operating
system you should be able to follow
along on any linux system the
instructions are actually fairly
straightforward so let's go ahead and
jump right into it
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to download two
files onto your computer and i'll put
links to them into the description
the first file is from this
downloads.raspberrypi.org
and the file is this 20170410
raspbian jesse.zip
this is the operating system image that
we are going to use in order to work
with um emulating this operating system
there are other versions of it there's
more recent versions this one is the one
that seems to work most stably with qmu
so it's the one that i am going to be
utilizing
now in addition to this we're also going
to need a kernel that is working for
this operating system and we can get
that from this github link again i'll
put this into the description as well
this github link is going to give you
this qmu 4.4.34 hyphen jesse file
if you go to the root of this you can
actually see all the different kernels
that we have so we have support for a
variety of different types of kernels
this one is the one that corresponds
with our operating system though so
we're going to go ahead and download
this one
once you have these files downloaded
i've placed them inside of this qmu
underscore vms folder you can put it
anywhere on your computer it doesn't
really matter um and you're going to
want to unzip this
2017.0410 raspbian jesse.zip file to
turn it into that img file that i have
in the directory as well
once you have this available i want you
to install qmu and you can do that using
sudo apt get install q
mu system so i've already installed this
it will take a number of minutes on your
computer depending on how fast it is um
and then once it's completed you will be
good to go
once you have that all set we're going
to go ahead and just run our emulator
and the way that we do that is we say
qmu hyphen system hyphen arm
and then hyphen kernel
and i'm going to direct it towards the
kernel that we downloaded which is in
qmu underscore vm slash kernel this file
here
we then want to give it the cpu that we
want to use for the emulation i'm going
to use arm 1176 again this is the one
that seems to work most reliably with
this particular distribution so it's the
one that i will show um hyphen m is the
amount of ram or virtual ram that we
want to allocate so i'll say 256. uh
that's a good size for this
hyphen capital m is the emulated machine
type we are going to use uh versatile pb
this one is just like one of the various
types that's included with qmu again one
that works very well for this particular
example
we're going to provide a serial as scdio
just to allow everything to work through
our standard input output
and then i'm going to use the append
command to append the following we're
going to say root dev sda2
uh
root fs type equals ext4 read write
this just helps us set up the general
file system that we're emulating so this
gets everything set up the way that we
need it
and i'm going to put hyphen hda and i'm
going to point it towards the iso that
we have on our computer so that is in
qmu underscore vms slash
2017 this one here to img
and then finally what i'm going to do is
i'm going to forward a port from this
computer to our ssh port which is 22 on
our machine
the reason i'm going to do this is
because
when you work through qmu it's a little
bit hard to get things to full screen
properly so rather than doing that what
i'm going to do is i'm going to ssh into
the emulator through my virtual machine
here
so to do that we can just do the
following we do hyphen nic
we're gonna say user comma f host
forward
equals tcp
and then two colons then five zero two
two
uh
and then twenty two
so 22 is the port that we're forwarding
so that's the ssh port 5022 is the port
that we're forwarding to so when we want
to connect to ssh on this computer we're
going to use the port 5022 so that'd be
the idea of this
and then when we launch this we're going
to say no reboot uh just because i don't
want the system to actually reboot i
just want it to boot as is
once we do this um
it looks like maybe i just spelt this
wrong the machine type uh let me just
double check it should be
versus
versus tile yes it's about wrong so you
versatile pb like this
now once we run this you should see that
your qmu starts to boot
so this is booting into the raspberry pi
operating system if you've gotten this
far congratulations you now have a
raspberry pi machine running on your
computer um i will note that it's a
little bit tricky to get this working
reliably um i am able to get it working
reliably every time that i've tried it
so far on my computer which is why i'm
showing this set of instructions if you
have any troubles with getting things
set up uh it should be relatively easy
to troubleshoot the errors that you're
getting but feel free to comment them as
well and i will try to help you as much
as i can i also plan to try to post this
image if possible somewhere so that it's
able to be downloaded so keep an eye out
on the description as well i'm gonna try
to put a link to this virtual machine
image so that you're able to access it
and use it rather than having to do all
this setup yourself that way you get one
that is for certain working through
virtualbox and then from there you can
just sort of fiddle around and get it to
work on your particular system there's a
few things like setting up emulation
inside of emulation like allowing
virtualbox to run emulators like this
there may be some settings that you need
to tweak in virtualbox to get that to
work but um regardless again it should
be relatively easy to uh get set up if
not just feel free to leave some
comments i'll try to help you with
troubleshooting some of those errors if
possible
so once we have things set up here what
i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna run the
following command i'm gonna open up the
terminal on this emulated device
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
forward ssh on it so i'm going to say
sudo
service
ssh start
once that runs successfully we're going
to just try sshing into this machine
through my computer and see what happens
so it looks like everything is good to
go
i'll create a new tab here let's zoom it
in a little bit
i'm going to ssh pi at 127.0.0.1
and then the port like i said before is
gonna be five zero zero two or five zero
two two rather
when that goes through ask you if you
wanna continue you can say yes
the password for this is raspbian
r-a-s-or sorry it's um i think it's
raspberry pi
okay well let's let's double check and
see what it is uh
you want to say raspbian password
ah it should be raspberry so raspberry
should be the default password let's
just try that
there we go so now it has brought us
into our device and we are now inside of
our emulated device
so with this we now have an arm device
that is running on a linux system and
now we're going to be able to do a lot
of really cool and interesting things
with arm we're going to learn about
things like system and software
interrupts um and we're going to really
just build up a lot of operating system
understanding as well and really dig
deeper into the sort of things that we
can do with arm assembly so thank you
for watching this video i hope that you
enjoyed it again if you have any sort of
trouble throughout this process please
do leave comments let me know i'll try
to help out as much as possible and i'm
sure some of the other viewers will be
able to help out too
and then we'll be able to get things up
and running like this and then we'll be
able to learn all these different
operating system techniques so again
thank you for watching and i'll see you
in the next video
in this video we're going to start to
take a look at operating system
interactions by seeing how we can output
data onto the screen so we're finally
going to do like an actual formal hello
world program where we output hello
world onto the screen and while we're
doing this we're going to explore the
ideas of system calls and system
interrupts
done through our assembly
so let's go ahead and get started for
the purposes of these videos i'm going
to be working through our raspberry pi
in this case i'm actually logged onto a
physical machine but you can use the
emulator we set up in the previous video
or you can use a physical machine of any
kind that has an arm processor if you
want to follow along on something
physical the choice is really yours it
should work on pretty much any arm based
device
so we're going to start off by creating
a new file which i'm going to call hello
world i'm going to do that through the
nano text editor and it's just my text
editor preference you can use whatever
you prefer
the extension for this files.s.s is the
typical file extension for assembly
based programs
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to set up our program in a very
similar way to what we have done in the
emulator past right so let's take a look
at how we set that up we say dot global
underscore start and then we have our
start label
and then for this we're going to need
some data and the data is going to be
what we actually want to print onto the
screen i'm going to do that declared as
a message
now we want this message to be text
there's a lot of different ways that we
can declare text in arm and i want to
discuss each of them now
the most basic type of text type is
ascii
ascii is just general characters and
there's something about the ask key
format that doesn't really work well for
a lot of text applications and that is
the fact that it is not null terminated
and what that means is basically in some
lower level programming languages if
you've programmed in c you'll be
familiar with this idea when we create a
string since it's really just like an
array of characters we have something
that indicates the end of the array of
characters because of course as we're
going into memory in memory it's not
always predictable what an empty slot of
memory will contain so what we do is we
pick a special character that indicates
the end of a string and we call that the
null terminator so it's a special
character set aside that always
indicates the end of a string the ascii
format does not have that so this sort
of format works best for things like
individual characters or situations
where we don't need the null terminator
in almost every single case though
you're going to want to have a null
terminator for your string so instead
we're going to use this here ascii zed
i'll call it and what this does is it
declares a string but it adds on a null
terminator at the end which allows us to
know where the end of the string
actually is
now one other note that i want to make
here is sometimes you might see dot
string dot string is actually an alias
for dot ask key set
so that dot string is the same as this
declaration here
so i just want to note that just in case
you ever see dot string it's the same as
this dot ascii set so those are the same
as each other it's a null terminated
string
and then from here we could just type in
the name or what what text we want right
so i could say hello world
i'm gonna put backslash n we could put
this new line character in so all that
does is it indicates a new line
backslash n
and essentially we can add that in
because it will get interpreted through
the operating system to write a new line
character
so that's something that we're able to
put in as well now i will eventually
show you what this looks like in memory
but for now we're just going to sort of
take this for granted and say okay this
will work and we will continue on with
this
now one other thing that i want to note
is that when you when you make the call
to write data to the screen in this case
which is what we're going to be doing
we're actually using components of the
linux operating system which is really
interesting sort of idea so you'll see
that from this point on when we start
using these system interrupts and system
calls there's gonna be a lot of
parallels between assembly and c so if
you're familiar with c it will be very
helpful for you if you're not familiar
with c not to worry we will eventually
discuss c and its concepts um in future
videos as well
so once we've declared the text here
what we could do is we could declare the
length of the text so i could say lin
equals
dot minus message
what this is going to do is it's going
to declare a variable called len and
it's going to be equal to the length of
message this is the way that we declare
that the way that this works is it
starts at the beginning of the text so
it starts at this h character here and
it continues moving through it until it
reaches that null terminator that i
mentioned previously once it reaches
that null terminator it knows it's
reached the end of the string that is
the length and it stores the length in
this len variable for us to use
so that is all the data that we're going
to need to create our hello world
program
now in order for hello world to work in
order for us to write data to the screen
we're going to need to declare and have
ready three different pieces of
information
the first piece of information is where
do we want to write the message or text
or data to
the second thing that we need is a
reference to tell us what one what we
want to actually output and the third
thing we want is the length how long is
the thing that we want to output and
those are gonna be stored in very
specific locations so we're gonna move
into r0 the value one
this one indicates that we want to place
uh that we want to place the output in
the standard output for our computer so
this would be the standard output which
is where all things output by default in
the case of me being ssh into my actual
computer the standard output would
typically be the command line interface
so it'd be without output so this is
generally the way that we output things
into the standard output
we can output the standard in by using
zero as our argument we can output to
standard error using two
as our inputs
now in general we can also add in
different values other than zero one and
two this will actually take in any valid
file descriptor as a an argument so we
can actually write the files as well for
those of you who are not as familiar
with the linux operating system in the
background what linux does is it assigns
things called file descriptors to the
files on the system what happens is when
you open up a file we are given a unique
identifier for that file which is
typically represented i believe as an
integer
and that allows us to know where we're
reading and writing from so whenever we
make calls to read and write to files we
use this file descriptor which is an
integer which uniquely identifies the
file
because this r0 is taking in some
integer value we can actually provide it
with any file descriptor of a file on
our system and it will actually write to
that file so that's something that's
interesting about this
now like i said before we also have to
give it the value that we want to print
as well as the length so we can do that
using ldrs so i can ldr into r1
the message
so it's going to load the address of
message like we've discussed previously
into r1 so i'll tell it where message is
currently located in memory so it's kind
of like a buffer right it tells it the
buffer location of the message
and then what we could do is we can ldr
into r2 the value of length
this places the length into register 2.
so now we know the length of the actual
string itself we know the actual string
that we want to print and we know where
we want to print it the last thing we
need to do is tell the computer to print
the thing to the screen
now the way that we do this is actually
quite interesting
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
move into r7 the value 4.
now that might seem a little bit random
what's happening here is when we
communicate with the operating system
r7 is a special register that actually
keeps track of what we want the
operating system to do so when we do an
interrupt which will allow the operating
system to take over the processing what
the operating system is going to do is
it's first going to look at register r7
and it's going to check what number is
written there that's going to tell the
operating system what it needs to do
next when i give it the value 4 what the
operating system sees is it sees that i
want to write something to this screen
it's then i'm going to take a look at r0
r1 and r2 to answer the questions of
where to write the data what data needs
to be written and what the length of
that data is
it will then write out the data and then
it will return back to the program to
allow it to continue executing that's
the general flow of what happens when we
do this sort of interrupt if we want to
go into a little bit more detail what's
actually happening here is in linux
there's a system called called write
what this is doing is it's actually
calling that write function and again if
you have familiarity with c programming
and specifically like system level c
programming you are likely familiar with
the write function you use that actually
to write files on a linux system that's
the same function that's being called
here we're just calling it through a
system call in a little bit more of an
abstract way so i just want to bring out
that parallel just in case you're
familiar with c programming because it's
a really valuable one to keep in mind uh
that we are actually able to communicate
with the system calls in this way
so we we've set up the value that is
needed in order to know which system
called to make now we have to make the
system call which we do using swi0
swi means software interrupt so what it
does is it interrupts and it tells the
operating system hey we need you to do
something the operating system helps us
handle hardware things like input and
output so it is able to do the output
for us again it takes a look at r7 it
sees the value four it says that's an
output it then outputs based on r1 r0 r1
and r2's values
once that is done it returns back to our
program and lets our program continue to
execute at this point what's going to
happen is we're going to flow into the
data and weird things are going to
happen
in order to prevent that we have to
properly tell our program to exit which
hasn't been something that we've really
had to do throughout the emulation type
videos
to do that what we do is we say move
into r7 the value 1 and then we do an
swi
so what's happening here is again we're
telling the operating system what we
need it to do the argument of one is
telling the operating system to
terminate our program so this time we do
our software interrupt the operating
system will interrupt it will take a
look at r7 it sees one and it says oh
that means i should terminate the
program and it will terminate it and we
will be done
so this is everything that's involved in
creating our simple hello world program
you can see it's it's not necessarily
all that simple but uh now that you have
a familiarity with a lot of the general
concepts of assembly hopefully this does
actually seem a little bit easy to
actually you do right so a lot of these
instructions are already familiar
there's a few new ones a few new
concepts but this should be relatively
straightforward hopefully
now the last thing that i need to show
you here is how to actually run your
program we're going to do two steps
we're going to first assemble the
program so we're going to do aos
holoworld.s hyphen o
hello
world.oh
this is creating an intermediar file
known as an object file the object file
can then be combined with other object
files if required and compiled into what
is called a binary the binary is what is
actually run on the system to execute
the code so to create the binary we do
ld
hello world.oh
hyphen o hello world
so you can see right now we have three
files we have hello world which is the
binary i just created hello world.o
which is the object file
and then hello world.s which is our
assembly code
now we want to execute hello world we do
dot slash hello world
and as you can see hello world is
printed to the screen so it looks like
everything is working as expected
so from this video you should now have a
better understanding of how system calls
work and how we're actually able to
output data onto the screen so thank you
for watching this video in the next
video i'm actually going to walk through
gdb to show you how you can get a better
understanding of the actual layout of
memory on this linux system because you
can't really see a lot of the details
just running it i want to show you how
to debug and understand the code that
you're running with a little bit better
than what we have now so thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
video in this video we're going to take
a look at how we can actually debug our
assembly programs through the linux
command line and what i want to do is i
want to show you that a lot of the
things that we saw in our online
emulator can also be replicated through
the actual linux command line using
programs like gdb and that's primarily
what we're gonna focus on we're gonna
take a look at the same program that we
had before that was this uh this hello
world program that was able to print out
hello world to the screen i'm going to
show you how we can step through it and
see all of the different pieces that are
required in order to make this work
so first off we're going to launch this
program into debug mode using gdb which
is a debugger that comes typically
default on most linux distributions and
it's a really valuable debugger for
assembly as well as other programs like
c you'd often see it used with
so to do this we just do gdb and then we
type in the name of our program which is
hello
world and you'll see that we'll get this
screen that will say all this
information about gdb and that it's been
launched successfully
so in order to get this running what we
have to do is we have to add in a
breakpoint what a breakpoint is going to
do is it's going to stop the execution
of our program at a point specified by
us allowing us to be able to see what
the current state of the memory is at
that point and step through to the next
instruction and continue stepping one by
one the typical thing that we break on
is we break on the start label so we
break underscore start
so what this will do is when we run our
program it will stop at that start label
and allow us to start executing step by
step from there
so once we have our break point set we
could just type in run
and you'll see that it started the
program and it's hit the breakpoint at
start
now you can't really see any of this
information right now so what we have to
do is we have to change the layout of
gdb so we could say layout
asm
and you can see that this gives us a
layout that shows all of the
instructions in our application so you
can see the first instruction which is
moving one into r0 and then we have the
loading of our strings and our length
and then we have our system call and
then we have our end of our program with
the system call for that
so this is giving us an idea of how we
can actually look at the instructions
that are associated with our program
now the next question is how do we see
the registers there's two different ways
that you could typically see the
registers the first is you could say
info
register and then type in the register
that you want info on so i could type in
for instance r0
oh sorry i have to do it as a lower case
r so it'd be info register
r0
and you can see that it has a value of
zero so there's there's nothing
currently in it it's set to zero
currently so that's one way that we
could see the register
another way that we could see the
register is we can actually type in
layout
regs
and you can see that that will show all
the registers above our
instructions now what you could do is
you could type in control
x
and then o
and that will allow you to switch
between the instructions and the
register so you can see now i can scroll
with the arrow keys and i could see each
of the different registers that exist
you can see like the stack pointer
the link register the program counter
the cpsr registers you can see all that
information that we would typically have
when we were running through the
emulator again that's control x
and then type o after doing that and
that will let you switch your interface
between the layout asm and the layout of
registers so you can have both of them
going and switch between them with
control x o
now from here we can step to the next
instruction using step i so i type in
step i
and you could see that it highlights the
next line so it executed the first line
and moves on to the next one
and we can confirm that because if i
look up at my register view i see that
r0 has been set to 1 which is what
happens when we do this move instruction
right we move r 1 into r 0 and we can
see that that actually did happen
let's step by again
and you can see what's happened now is
it's loaded our string into r1 and you
can see that it has the address of the
string now stored in r1 now the next
thing i'm going to talk about here is
well how do we actually see the string
in memory so how do we actually see the
stock memory
the way that we do this is we do the
following we do x
slash
so basically what x is doing is it's
saying examine so we're going to examine
a part of memory and then what we have
to do is we have to tell
gdb how many pieces of memory do we want
to analyze and what format do we want to
see it in so for example you could say
10 x what that would do is it would show
us 10
hexadecimal memory slots so what's going
to happen is we specify a starting point
so i would say address so say i want to
see the address of r1 i put dollar sign
r1
what's going to happen is it's going to
start at the address of r1 which is 2009
and it's going to show me 10
hexadecimals starting at that point so
it starts at 20098 and then it goes to
the next memory slot and then the next
one until it showed me 10 hexadecimal
values
you can see when i press enter that's
exactly what happens right so we see um
the two zero zero nine eight
right this is the first slot and then
the second slot and then the third
fourth fifth all the way up to ten right
so you can see that that generally shows
us the hexadecimal values now looking at
these values here it's not necessarily
clear what each of these represents
right we could see that each of these is
a single piece of our stack memory you
know this really parallels the same
ideas as our emulator right nothing's
really changed there's still the same
number of like hexadecimal values per
slot of memory we're still working with
32 bits for every single
piece of memory here right so you can
see that we have 10 32-bit slots that's
what's really happened here now of
course looking at the hexadecimal
numbers is a little bit confusing so
what you can actually do is you could
specify different formats i could view
these in decimal by changing the x to a
d
like this
you can see that it gives us decimal
values again still not entirely clear so
let's do something different we can
actually specify character using 10c so
c is character d is decimal uh just to
give you a few more here u is unsigned
decimal so that sort of gives you all
the same ones that you would have had in
the emulator right x for hexadecimal d
for decimal uh u for unsigned decimal
but then we also have this c for
character which is nice
when i do this one what you'll see
is our string right hello world i don't
quite have enough uh numbers here let me
put in um 15 should be enough
yeah you see there we go we have hello
world backslash n and then you see that
backslash zero zero zero here let me
highlight it here
this right here is the null terminator
that i was talking about it's the
special character that indicates the end
of the string so that's something
interesting to sort of point out here
that's the null terminator for our
string
so you could see that this is each of
the different values that exists inside
of our memory right you can actually see
that each of these does represent the
characters that we were expecting right
we have the hello world string with the
null terminator and the backslash n for
the new line all stored in stack memory
so this allows you to actually see
what's being stored in that memory so
you could see that you have a lot of the
same troubleshooting techniques as we
had when we are working in the actual
emulator itself
and again we can continue through this
we can continue stepping through as much
as we'd like
you could see that we have generally the
length of the string being stored and
then we do our system calls and you know
we move on as as is right um if you want
to just like complete the execution you
can just type in run again and what will
happen is um
well actually run will take us back to
the beginning um we can remove the break
point for instance and then run it again
but generally the way they interact with
the application through gdb would be
stepping through step by step to sort of
debug problems and then the way that you
would run it is what we saw in the
previous video where we did the dot
slash uh you know and then running the
program as is
so this should hopefully give you a bit
of a better understanding of how we can
actually debug our applications and
you're going to see this a fair bit
whenever we're working in assembly i'm
going to be using this debugger to sort
of show you the general idea of what is
happening when we're going through each
of these different memory locations
so not to worry you'll get a lot of
practice with this and i recommend just
trying it out with a few of the other
programs that we've done so far try
writing them in this linux
format and then try debugging them and
just see what happens you know it will
help you a lot with understanding the
various components of gdp
so thank you so much for watching this
video and i will see you in the next one